Hey,
what's happening folks,
this episode of the podcast is brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is a
website that allows you to send things from your home using your home computer,
your home printer,
printing up official US postage.
Never have to leave the house again to send things.
If you go to stamps.com click on the old school microphone in the upper right
hand corner and they enter in the code word j r e you will get a $110 bonus
offer which includes a digital scale,
uh,
up to $55 in free postage and a no risk trial.
And then what this means as far as like what you have to do if you have,
if you have a home business or if you send things out of your office,
it's a huge pain in the ass to have to send someone to go to the post office,
weigh each individual package,
print up postage for each individual package at the post office.
It's,
it's just very annoying and you don't have to ever do that again with stamps.com
with stamps.com the digital scale that they provide you weighs out the package.
You print the exact postage from your home computer,
official us postage,
boom on the package.
Mailman shows up.
You hand that to him and you're done.
It really truly is that simple.
If you go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone in the upper right hand corner and enter in the code.
Word J.
R e can't recommend them enough.
I know a lot of folks that use that.
Brian uses it for desk squad.
Dot TV.
Uh,
Bert Kreischer uses it for Bert Bert,
bert.com Tom Segura and Christina Palicki.
Use it for the you your mom's house podcast.
It's an excellent,
excellent service.
Makes things way more convenient for you.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything,
click on the upper right hand corner microphone,
the old school microphone and entering the Code Word J r e for your special
offer.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that is o n n I t at on it.
We have a a new version,
a new and improved version of t plus along with a a new study that came out
about t plus that increased his strength up to 36% faster than placebo.
One of the things we tried to do it on a.com or one of the things we do do is
anything that we have that's controversial.
First of all,
we provide,
if you click on any of the links for any of the supplements,
click on the research page.
Everything is thoroughly researched and put on on at.com with references to all
the tests that have been done on all the various supplements,
double blind placebo controlled tests on both Alpha brain and now on a t plus
and also all the tests that we didn't do that already exist on supplements like
new mood.
All the research is available online and on.
It has a 100% money back guarantee on any of the supplements that we sell.
You don't have to return the product.
You have 30 day or you have 90 days to uh,
for the first 30 pills.
When you buy a bottle,
the first 30 pills,
you have 90 days to try it out.
Try it.
You don't like it.
Just say this stuff,
socks,
you get your money back.
What we're counting on is that we're providing you with excellent supplements
that are gonna enhance your life.
That's all we're trying to do.
And if we do that,
then we've got a customer.
And if we don't do that,
and then with bold part our separate ways and everyone's good,
go to onnit.com o n n I t and if you use the Codeword Rogan,
you will save 10% off any an all supplements.
We got all kinds of shit at on it.
If you're thinking about getting your life in order,
we have strength and conditioning equipment,
kettlebells,
battle ropes,
steel maces steel clubs.
We have a,
we have everything you could think of.
Medicine,
balls,
Chin up bars,
weight vests and along with a lot of exercise DVDs including the excellent Keith
Weber Kettle Bell Cardio extreme workout DVDs that a,
I swear by,
I use these all the time and Keith will be on next month.
Very excited to have him back on or have him on brother.
And um,
all the other exercise videos that we have are,
are excellent as well.
There's a gang of them online too.
If you don't feel like buying a DVD and you're thinking about starting a workout
program,
just plenty of stuff on youtube for free.
Um,
the one thing that I recommend,
I always do,
and I can't say it enough,
start slow.
If you're the type of person that just isn't,
you haven't exercised before or you're kind of lazy and you're like,
this is it.
I'm getting my shit together.
Please don't rush.
It starts slow.
Let your body build up,
write down your progress,
and if you can,
if you can afford it,
go to a trainer.
Go to a trainer at least at first and have someone film it just to make sure
you're doing the proper form.
The last thing you want to do is hurt yourself when you're trying to get your
shit together.
All right,
fuckers.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com o.
N N.
I t.
Use the codeword Rogan again and save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
Mike Baker is here.
We're going to find out some shit.
We're going to get down to business.
Cue The music.
Jamie,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
Oh righty.
Mike Baker,
first of all,
start.
Thank you very much for joining us.
We appreciate you.
Thank you.
Love the podcast and by the way,
the Codeword Rogan may not be that secure as a code word,
but it's a good one.
It's a terrible code.
Works as far as security.
Know.
If it was your Wifi Password,
I would say,
uh,
you're in deep.
You've got to change that.
Then,
well,
coming from you,
you,
you know about some shit.
Uh,
you're,
you're a former,
we'll explain what you did.
You were the form of covert operations officer for the CIA.
I,
uh,
went in and I was recruited in the agency,
and the,
and the CIS,
uh,
divided into,
a handful of directorates.
You've got the director of operations,
which is pretty much what it sounds like.
Uh,
you've got the director of intelligence,
which is where they put all the smart people and they do all the reports
writing.
They take all the raw intelligence is coming in from the field and they put into
some usable form that can then be kicked out the door to the National Security
Council.
The White House.
It's,
it's used by the other agencies in the Intel community and primarily by the
White House.
So a lot of smart people sitting over there.
Then they've got s and t,
which is science and technology.
That's where you get all the gear.
So that's where they develop all,
I mean they've developed in the agency over the years.
Everything from the youtube to a stealth technology drone capability.
All a lot of the drone technology came right out of the agency.
They've done a tremendous number of things,
uh,
right there in house.
And then we have the administrative logistics group and they're incredibly
important because they keep uh,
money and gear and everything else flowing out to the field.
What is the biggest misconception about the CIA knew being,
you know,
a guy who worked with them for years.
Like I know that there's all sorts of wacky conspiracies out there about
everything.
Anything that there is,
where people don't have all the facts and information,
there's going to be wacky conspiracies.
Look,
I know a bunch of wacky conspiracies just about the UFC.
There were the ridiculous and me knowing the actual inside truth.
I hear these things and I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Things that I'm supposed to say,
the things that I had to do,
because you know,
the UFC made me or they said you have to say this,
which is all 100% bullshit,
right?
What's,
what are the big misconceptions?
No,
you're absolutely right.
And,
and the agency is,
is a,
it's like,
it attracts this sort of thing,
right?
It attracts sort of the Byzantine theories and the conspiracy theories and all
that.
Because again,
there's a reason why you have secrets.
There's a reason why you protect sources and methods.
And so because you don't have transparency that people would like to see,
they assume that you're out to fuck him over.
You're out the screw of the world.
And,
and that's just not the case.
So I guess the number one conspiracy as it's somehow the CIA and the Intel
community of the u s is a involved in some one world government that they're
basically out the fuck everybody and they're not,
the agency has an incredibly,
a political organization.
It doesn't matter who's in charge of the White House.
You get your task and you march on.
And that's a really good thing because a lot of other countries over there,
including a lot of our allies,
they have very politicized intel community.
So every time you get a change in leadership,
you know,
I'll go some people,
it comes from New People and they're beholden to the,
uh,
to the White House.
So that's one of the things,
you know,
I suppose the other thing would be,
um,
that we've got nothing but hot chicks walking around the building.
And if you walk in,
we got wonderful people,
but we,
you know,
we don't have that many hot chicks.
Isn't that because a homeland?
Yeah,
exactly.
One show fucked it up for everybody.
Yeah.
Alias and all the,
all the other movies,
a beach books,
you know,
everybody's supposed to be hot in the AC.
I was disappointed too.
I mean,
when I started there,
I got in for my first couple of days of training.
I kept thinking,
why are they hiding them or they someplace else,
or a lot of really great people.
But you know,
the quote of hot chicks was,
was less than I expected.
You bring up an interesting point about being a political.
Now that's one thing that a lot of people worry about when it comes to
organizations that they may have more power.
In fact then the political governing body that controls the country.
One of the big theories about the CIA with the CIA had Kennedy killed because
Kennedy was trying to get rid of the CIA.
I mean,
it wasn't that one of the big,
that was what,
that was one of the big ones and that's still endearing.
Um,
I did,
uh,
I cohost a show on travel channel,
American declassified,
right?
That was the first season.
It's going to their changing the title for the second season.
But in the first season we,
uh,
we,
we looked at the Kennedy assassination and absolutely I talked to a number of
people who have been involved in,
in,
uh,
studying that for a long time.
And there you,
you'll never going to shift him off that position that the agency was involved.
And there's a lot of people out there.
And part of it is because
again,
there's no transparency and people assume the worst if they don't get exactly
what they want to hear.
And people like conspiracy theories anyway,
they always want it.
Yeah,
that's fine.
fine.
Yeah.
What's not to like
you,
uh,
you interviewed that Jim Marrs guy on your show,
American declassified,
and he's,
uh,
he's,
he's an interesting cat.
He's a full on nutter,
right?
I'll stick with,
he's an interesting cat.
He's a full on nutter slash interesting cow and he's a,
he's all about Ua foes and bases on the moon.
That's not bases on the moon.
I mean,
there may be that part that,
yeah,
I can confirm that.
But uh,
as far as the Kennedy assassination goes,
again,
it's,
it's one of those things you could see why at the end of not,
I don't want it disappeared on that rabbit hole.
But you can see why at the end of that story,
that episode when we talked to a lot of people,
we did a lot of research.
You can see why they,
the theory still holds a conspiracy is still out there.
What do you think happened with Kennedy?
Do you think Oswald acted alone?
Yeah.
You know what,
I think that,
um,
once you get inside there,
we got really good access into that and that's part of what the show's about.
But we had really good access into that window,
that very spot where,
you know,
he took the shots.
Now he wasn't,
he wasn't Lex Luther,
but he had enough training.
And when you look at the distance involved,
the line of sight,
the weather conditions,
the lighting addition to the fact that he reconned that target or that site
beforehand,
because he worked there,
he had every advantage he needed.
And so the idea that he could make those shots with the,
with the training that he had received from the marines,
again,
he would,
you know,
was he the world's greatest?
Never.
Of course not.
But he had enough.
And also he had an element of luck going forward,
which you always need an operations.
So I think,
I think he took the shots.
Now.
I also think that he was in his mind,
he felt he was doing this because he was desperate to join.
At that point.
He was desperate to join the Cuban revolution.
He had been very disappointed by is time spent over in Russia.
And he had come back and he was looking for something and he felt,
this is my theory.
He felt that this was going to get him in with Castro by doing this.
And I honestly believe that.
Now here's the other part that's a bit of a wildcard.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the Cuban Intel service had a file,
a massive file on him,
courtesy of the Russians.
Of course,
the record.
I mean,
the Russians trained most of the Cuban Intel service at that time and they had
provided a great deal of information because Oswald had been living in Russia
for the time.
You married a Russian woman.
He,
you know,
worked in a radio factory and,
and,
and again had a very disappointing experience.
And the Russians were pretty much happy to get rid of him at that point because
he was,
you know,
it was serving no purpose.
And so by the time he had gotten back to the states,
the Cubans already had a big file on him.
Now he had also gone to Mexico.
There was an unexplained trip that he had taken down in Mexico City,
so do do I think that there's a potential that probably not a directed by the
Cuban government,
but probably in his mind thinking,
this is how I do it.
This is how I get in.
This is,
he was,
I mean he was a sociopath,
but
I think he's,
one of the things that bugs me about people,
the way they look at the Kennedy assassination is that it's either Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone or it was a conspiracy and Lee Harvey Oswald wasn't a part of
it,
and my thoughts were always like,
why would you assume that he wasn't a part of it?
Just because people said there were shots from other directions.
First of all,
we all know that eye witness accounts are some of the most unreliable accounts
ever.
Absolutely.
People see things that aren't there that hear things.
They remember things completely wrong that if,
especially in the traumatic event,
your adrenaline fires up,
your heart rate goes up.
There's shots going off,
you hear things,
but it was behind me.
Michael Brown.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
that's another,
we'd go down that rabbit hole too.
But the,
the thing that drives me crazy about the Kennedy assassination too is when they
show Lee Harvey out,
when they try to disprove it,
like Jesse Ventura did a show where he tried to disprove it.
He was holding a rifle in his arm.
He was,
he was cocking it and firing it,
but he was standing holding it and I'm like,
you got a window sill.
If you're trying to hit something accurately,
why would you hold it in your arm?
Why wouldn't you rest it on that window sill when you're resting it on something
you,
it's incredibly stable.
You don't have to be a master marksman.
And when you have a rifle resting down on something,
all it is,
is about not flinching.
It's a platform and it's going to give you some stability.
And,
and we looked at that with,
with the Mlk,
with Martin Luther King assassination to um,
and you know,
the fact that the show was taken out of a bathroom window and it was clear given
the that that yes,
common sense tells you and the in the physical nature of that tells you that he
rested the,
the weapon on the window sills.
So you look at Oswald and again Oswald recky this site,
he knew what he was getting into.
He knew how he was going to take this shot and had had sufficient training from
the marines.
So I agree with him.
And that's typically with conspiracy theories.
It's typically always,
it's all one or it's all the other and the real world operates in a much
different murky or environment in that
no doubt,
no doubt.
But what bothers me about it,
there's a bunch of things that bothered me about it.
The,
the single bullet theory without a doubt bothers me because that doesn't make
any sense at all.
When you see that bullet showing up on Connolly's Gurney,
it's in pristine condition.
It's supposed to gone through two bodies is more cause bullet particles.
Fragments that are in Connally's bothered.
They showed up on an x ray.
They're not missing from that bullet.
That seems a little wonky.
And the whole reason Arlen Specter concocted that in the first place was because
they had to account for a bullet that hit a curb stone under the overpass.
Guy got hit with a ricochet.
Now they've attributed three bullets to this one guy shooting.
They have to attribute all these wounds to one bullet for this theory to make
any sense.
That to me is the biggest hole in the
the conspiracy.
Right.
And that's,
and I mean at the end of our episode and for what it's worth,
I mean we basically include looked like it.
It's clear there are issues here that remain and are they likely to be solved?
Probably not.
Given the fact that a lot of people have passed away some in,
you know,
odd circumstances.
We looked at that issue to the people that,
you know,
the died.
Oh Shit.
The,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so,
but again,
uh,
you know,
our point was not this,
I think anytime you set out to disprove a conspiracy theory or prove it,
you're,
you're going to be left unsatisfied.
But the disproved part was wonky though.
The holding the gun was Wonky,
like the why would he hold it?
And the other thing was warranted.
They said the site was off.
We check the rifle,
the site was off.
Well,
this is in person.
I can tell you I wounded a deer once that I was trying to kill because I dropped
a rifle,
I fell,
I dropped the rifle and the site went off like that.
You could take us,
you've got a rifle,
you're moving it around from the crime scene,
you're putting it somewhere else,
you putting in cars and then you test it.
You can't tell me that rifle sight was off when he shot it because you don't
know.
Right.
You don't,
you don't know.
And you're absolutely right.
It,
you know,
how sensitive those things can and particularly older technology.
All right.
So,
uh,
I mean some of the,
some of the gear now is pretty robust and,
and designed to stand up to pretty difficult conditions,
but you know,
that gear that you know,
it,
it's old,
it's old and it,
and you're absolutely right.
It went from place to place to place a secret service for storing at the bureau
was storing and everybody was,
you know,
had their hands on it.
Yeah.
But if he had it cited in,
if it was accurate at the time and he's resting it on the window,
man,
that's a different animal.
Yeah.
My number one problem with is that single bullet theory,
this is the number one problem.
The other thing is this is approved or film.
There's a prude or film was weird because everybody points to the Zapruder film,
the whole back into the left,
back into the left.
You know,
you see Kennedy,
it looks like he's getting shot from the front.
But what they don't say is that the blood is kind of spring forward.
If you watch that video,
he's going back to the left,
but the,
the blood is,
is sprang forward almost as if he was hit twice.
Like he was hit with one bullet from the front and one bullet from the back.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
again,
it's one of those,
it's the movement of the vehicle.
It's,
it's,
it,
you know,
it's,
it's his immobility it to begin with.
I mean,
if he didn't have back problems,
you know,
he could have,
he probably,
he probably could have maneuvered himself out,
you know,
quick enough.
But Kennedy was fairly immobile.
That's a lot of things.
One of the things that people don't realize,
he was really sick before he died.
Yeah.
But yeah,
and it was,
again,
so I think the conspiracy things,
going back to your original point,
the agency is always just sort of ground zero for people's conspiracies.
Yeah.
Well,
there's so many people involved in it too.
One of the things that I found completely fascinating about this whole thing
with Patraeus is Patraeus got in trouble with the,
the FBI was investigating the CIA and there they,
you know,
the whole thing with the,
uh,
the emails,
like,
that seems to me to be so crazy that agencies investigate other agencies.
Is it really competition between like the CIA and the FBI?
Well,
you know what,
it's better than it used to be.
I mean,
I remember when,
uh,
when the,
when the bureau started going overseas,
uh,
when they started getting involved in,
in,
uh,
terrorism issues overseas,
um,
they would send their people out.
And I remember I was,
I was operating overseas and I remember we had a,
we had a meeting one time and I went into a,
to a,
to an embassy,
um,
because I said,
look,
you know,
we're gonna have a meeting.
Okay.
We were doing something out on the street.
So I'm up going in there and looking at our guys,
you know,
taking down,
maps and photos and charts and everything,
uh,
you know,
have this thing that was gonna happen and stuffing them in a desk.
And I said,
what's going on?
And they said,
well the bureau is coming in
so you know,
we've got to take all this yet.
We don't want them to see this stuff.
But the idea was we were,
you know,
working together and if you're out on the street,
I mean our natural response was,
well I thought were working together cause I don't,
I don't want to get my ass caught out there.
If,
you know,
if we could tell them something that would make sense.
But you know,
also at the same down,
the bureau was telling us about 50% of what they knew.
And so there was,
there was a lot of uh,
uh,
difficulties.
Some of it highlighted after nine 11 that was talked about a lot.
So I don't want to go into that.
Everybody talked about other than didn't need to play well with others.
And so it's got,
it has gotten a lot better.
We've got a much better relationship.
And I personally,
because I work with them and I've worked with them a lot in the past,
I,
I have a little great deal of appreciation for the bureau.
And so that side of things has gotten a lot better.
It's never going to get perfect.
Well no,
because you know,
it's human nature.
It's human nature.
Yeah.
You're pissing on each other's turf sometimes and you know that.
And now the agencies in a,
in a bit of a different situation,
I mean the bureau has bigger issues with ATF and some others because they're all
kind of focused on law enforcement in some capacity.
And,
and uh,
my old outfit,
you know,
we've got a different focus so it doesn't usually surface.
And when it does,
it's typically in a,
in a terrorist concern.
Um,
so,
but I,
it is better.
It is better.
Look at,
look at me,
Mr Rosie.
I've got,
I've got my glass half full and by the way,
the coffees and I shoot,
you're not this,
we talked about it before,
but this is great.
Coffee.
Yeah,
it's delicious.
That's caveman coffee,
really.
Columbia.
Um,
the,
the thing about it is,
is it because everybody wants to take credit?
Is it like,
you know,
the FBI wants to take credit for catching bad guys and the CIA is going after
the same people and they're competing to reach the finish line first.
Is that what it is
in part,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
I'd probably be lying if I said there's not an element that's gotta be an
element of that,
right?
Everybody's competitive and you,
and these are two very tight they organizations,
but part of it is also just the feeling like you've got,
you know what you're doing,
you've got the process and you,
you,
and your process is better.
And there's also an aspect of it.
Law enforcement looks at,
at,
uh,
as an example,
law enforcement looked at sources differently,
right?
The agency is all about developing sources and,
and maintaining those and building on them.
Because what are you trying to do?
You're trying to gather intelligence,
right?
So we're not trying to,
at the end of the day,
uh,
you know,
the bus,
somebody,
I mean,
maybe at the end of an operation we're looking to terminate them.
But I mean that's,
that's a different story.
I just forget I said that.
But,
uh,
at the,
at the end of the day that law enforcement and you know,
oftentimes it's like,
let's,
we've got a source of great,
we don't mind burning that source because we're after the bus to where after,
you know,
some,
some gear or whatever it is.
Um,
and so there's a,
there's a fundamental difference there sometimes and the way that we view our
assets.
Um,
but oftentimes,
yeah,
I,
you can't disregard the fact that it's,
it's professional pride.
It's always there.
It's always a conflict in every movie where there's like cops and,
and you know,
and the FBI comes in,
we're taking over this investigation.
Shit,
this is all case.
You know,
that's,
that's so common in the captain's office.
Chew your ass out.
Yeah.
They have control of this crime scene.
Like you motherfucker.
And then they leave.
That's,
that's so we just wrote a show,
didn't I think we did and it's already been done a million times.
Unfortunate.
Yeah.
The CIA guys always end up looking like Douche bags in the,
um,
in the frankly in the movies or in the shelves.
I mean that's,
but where we were used to that frankly,
we just like getting washed up on Capitol Hill and having our ass kicked every
now and then.
Well,
not on homeland,
on homeland.
You guys look pretty good.
That's true.
The agency people watch homeland and go away.
Uh,
you know what,
this is gonna sound weird,
but I don't watch any of that.
I don't,
I,
I'm a terrible person to sit down and my wife refuses to sit with me and,
and even tried to start watching something like that because I,
you know,
I know that she's irritated when every time I start Kinda squirming and go,
no,
the fuck,
you know what?
I'm making noises,
you know,
and I'm kind of like a shifting around and she's finally just as hell.
Fuck it.
Just go somewhere else.
Hi.
Can,
I can understand like did that,
when I watched punchline with Tom Hanks and Sally fields,
I'll say exactly what did they have lockers.
Nobody has a locker room and you guys don't get lockers.
Have Walkers.
What do you put your,
we don't have anything.
Sports gear.
Your jockstrap fucking lacrosse stick.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
But is there anybody who's gotten it right?
Is there like any movie or anything that you've ever seen?
We like,
that's pretty damn close.
You know,
there's some old school ones when you talk about straight up trade craft,
when you're talking about old school espionage,
then things like,
uh,
Smiley's people,
some of the old sort of BBC shows.
Oh,
I don't know if that is,
what does Smiley's people,
it's an old,
uh,
what does it look,
Carrie?
I think that,
uh,
that wrote it.
I'm not sure,
but it's a,
it's,
it has,
it hasn't been airing for a long,
long time.
Uh,
but that was good.
The Good Shepherd is a movie,
the Good Shepherd.
I thought it was very interesting.
It.
It kind of dragged on for a while and,
and honestly,
who could believe that?
You know,
if you're married to Angelina Jolie,
you're going to want to like go away all the time.
That would be annoying.
After awhile.
I don't
know,
a week with her on an island somewhere,
you'd be like,
all right bitch,
I'm shipping it longer than a week.
Yeah,
I would have to give it longer than the way you're a patient,
man.
I am a patient,
but I think that uh,
those,
those were great.
They did a show.
Full disclosure,
I,
I worked on the show from its inception called spooks in the UK and it was a,
it was called a am my five over here in the states and it aired for a number or
several seasons.
It was actually,
I think probably the most successful show in,
in UK television history.
And then it ran for about eight years as a drama.
More successful than top gear.
Well,
yeah,
no,
not,
not that,
but I mean like a drama.
Typically what they do is if they get success with a drama or a comedy,
they just stop it because they feel guilty because,
I don't know,
it's a British thing,
but they,
this thing ran for eight seasons.
Um,
they did a very good job of,
of,
you know,
not focusing on the explosions and the car chases and everything.
And it was,
it was more about trade craft and things that were going on,
um,
to accomplish an operation.
But,
uh,
I liked the Bourne series.
I think,
you know,
I know that that's not realistic,
but I like that.
I know it's so unrealistic,
but I like the pacing of it.
I liked it.
You know,
I'll usually the,
yeah,
the filming is great that the moon,
so as a way to just,
because it's so obviously not realistic.
It's great.
[inaudible] you can get to immerse in it.
The ones I have trouble with it where they try to,
you know,
they throw a little something or they're trying to make it look like they know
what they're doing and then you think of it fuck sake.
But yeah,
the Bourne series is more like a superhero show.
Exactly.
So you can,
you can kind of get lost in it a little bit easier.
My problem with the Bourne series is this is my major problem with it and
especially the last one.
It seems like they're pussified [inaudible] superheroes and tough guys.
And to the point where they never tried to get laid ever.
They have zero sexual attraction to the most beautiful women on the planet.
They have totally pure altruistic purposes to all of their actions.
Everything they do is noble.
Like this guy.
Who the Fuck Jeremy Renner?
Is that what I did?
I didn't see the last one,
the last one.
It's fucking ridiculous cause he's with this chick is hot as the fucking sun and
she's fawning over him and at the end of the scene,
the end of the movie,
they're sitting apart from each other.
Like he saved her life about 150 fucking times she should be.
So he's,
he's handsome.
He's a stud.
He's kicked 150,000 people's asses in front of her.
Like,
she should be blown away by this guy and they should be,
or vice versa.
Yeah.
Both.
And they're leaving there on this boat and they're sitting apart from each
other.
Like as far apart as you and I are like,
they're not even hugging.
Like there's nothing like James Bond would have fucked her a million probably in
the first five minutes.
I mean,
that's the whole point of a bond movie.
But yeah.
No,
I know isn't that they were with a supposed to be a man of ranger out there
kicking ass and action.
Yeah,
no,
I believe me,
I go back to my point about the hot chicks.
When I first started the agency,
I thought that was,
that was kind of part of the deal.
But um,
this,
the,
the first three,
was it three,
the first three Bourne movies?
You're right.
It was the same way with,
uh,
with,
what's his name?
Um,
who played the role?
Oh yeah.
Matt Damon.
Uh,
it was,
it was always anxious ridden,
you know,
and if you got an indication that he might have just been banging one of the
girls that was in the movie,
it was,
he seemed like he was sorry about it and he was depressed about it because,
I don't know,
I'm not sure this is the right thing to do.
Trying to mute male sexuality when you're dealing with trained killers,
it doesn't make any sense.
I mean,
it's like the polar opposite of what we can say.
Like if you think about the ancient warriors to think about like gladiator or
any of these ancient warriors,
you connect these ancient warriors with,
they would fight and they would fuck.
But these Bourne identity guys,
there's no fucking,
no,
not saying it wasn't interesting thing.
And I think who knows what they were,
what they were thinking.
I do think they were trying to make it seem as if they were just so angst ridden
that they were kind of above it all.
You know what I think they're doing?
I think they're doing the same shit they're doing with twilight there.
They're making things for chicks.
They're turning vampires and these fucking glittery,
glittery queers that like hang out in the forest and they don't hurt anybody.
It's madness.
They're doing this thing where they're turning into these romantic novels of
completely unrealistic behavior.
What they're doing.
Anybody out there wants success.
Just write like a tween book flew to Vampire,
uh,
and no sacks.
And I guess you're good to go.
But the thing is,
is not tweens.
It's grown.
Women want their shit too.
It's this weird fantasy thing that it plays off of.
It's,
I don't understand it.
The female psyche is a mystery to me and dude,
I had to everyone,
but I'm with you on that one.
Although I am married to the world's greatest woman,
so no,
you're not.
So good luck.
But we always have the same girl.
We're not good.
God.
How we found that out?
That would be crazy.
Oh my God.
You know,
when your kids look like they look like your kids look like you.
So well,
we've solved that issue here today.
Uh,
yeah.
Dot.
She's a,
she's an absolutely terrific,
and she,
uh,
she,
from Idaho and that's where we've good stock.
Yeah.
We moved back there.
Beautiful Man in New York.
So at quarter lane,
man,
that lake up there,
I was holy shit.
That was just up there.
And it is fantastic.
And other places,
McCall red fish lake,
you know,
pay it like just beautiful,
beautiful,
stunning,
just stunning part of the country.
Do you guys get a lot of wolves up there?
Uh,
yeah.
And they delisted walls because,
right.
So,
you know,
if get a wolf problem,
shoot the fucker.
But,
um,
it's,
you know,
people don't understand that.
It's just like people,
you know,
people trying to dictate what you do with public lands when they have no
experience dealing with public lands and their state.
You know,
and that's kind of the way things work nowadays.
Uh,
but yeah,
she,
uh,
she from Idaho went back east.
I met her out there,
uh,
when she was working with us,
a lobbying firm.
And I came home one day from uh,
from,
uh,
we were living in,
in new Canaan,
Connecticut,
which is a nice little town outside
of New York,
but I was on metro north riding the train back and forth where my office is in
midtown,
walked in the door.
So,
you know,
I don't think I have to be here to do what what I do,
which is basically you just travel for the,
for the business.
And within a week she had the house in the market.
Within five weeks we were settled in Idaho.
Wow.
Fantastic.
Yeah,
it worked out.
Did you know anybody out there,
you just,
I,
you know,
I didn't,
we'd been going out there to hunt and fish and raft and climb and ski over the
past handful of years.
So I knew the area,
but I didn't know anybody but she knew a lot of people.
She,
and so,
you know,
we've settled in very nicely.
It's so calm out there and that's the thing that people don't appreciate.
The folks that are like stuck in the rat race of la or New York or anywhere with
is unbelievable.
Like the piece that you can get in a place like Montana or Idaho,
it's just beauty of the nature.
It's something that if you can do it,
I mean,
if you don't have a job that requires you to be in a city,
right?
And then,
you know,
more and more people I think have,
have the opportunity sometimes to be able to do that.
But you can fool yourself into thinking that I gotta be here.
I got to be in this,
this epicenter,
whether it's Los Angeles or Chicago in New York or wherever,
and,
you know,
because hey,
it's an important place.
And so therefore I'm important,
you know?
But I,
you know,
I sat on that train,
long enough going back and forth to,
to realize I wasn't that important.
So I figured,
Hey,
it's time to move.
But it's worked out.
The quality of life is,
you know,
I sound like I'm with the Boise,
Idaho Chamber of Commerce.
It's beautiful.
Boise's beautiful.
It's clean air and people,
Nice,
great live music,
good bars and restaurants.
It's a,
it's,
you know,
Bsu is there a Boise State University?
Uh,
so it's,
it's,
it's just the right size.
And I got three little boys and I tell you what,
you know,
we're out in the fishing,
uh,
you know,
five minutes from the house.
We're up in the foothills.
Uh,
you know,
when they're old enough,
the hunting is great,
so that'll be good.
Yeah.
Idaho is beautiful.
There's a lot of great parts of this country that don't get enough credit.
Everybody likes to call the flyover states,
you know,
fly over between New York and La.
Yeah.
It's pretty weird.
It's weird.
But I think also because for the longest time,
culturally,
those spots weren't as rich.
But now because of the Internet,
everything has changed.
We were talking about this the other day,
people just,
they're not hicks anymore in the middle.
Right.
It's not the same.
It's not like nobody has books like everybody's online.
Like the little level of intelligence and awareness of the average folks,
like just in the middle of the country.
It's way different than it was 2013.
Right.
The flow of information much better.
And that's,
and that's helping them.
And then,
but you can,
you know,
I spent,
uh,
what about seven years,
in,
in the northeast and the New York City area.
And you know,
people in that area.
I got wonderful friends there,
but,
but a lot of folks can believe that the rest of the country thinks like they do.
And,
and,
or that they should,
because they just don't know any better because they're not right there.
They're not in the heartbeat of America as they would refer to it.
And you know,
you get outside that northeast corridor and in Washington DC in particular in
Washington d C it so far up its own ass that,
you know,
you realize that all this country and that's one of these things with this
travel channel show,
that's a pretty good plug,
wasn't it?
Um,
the great thing about that is being able to just go out and travel and see how
great this country is and how it,
like you said,
how many places there are to see.
And,
you know,
I spend most of my life overseas.
And so for me it's a real treat because we're going all over hell and back and
just,
it's,
it's an incredible country.
When you try to leave the CIA,
did they go,
um,
you sure do they go,
uh,
do you really want to do that?
Um,
what are you going to do when you go out?
You going to get on TV?
What are you going to talk about Mike?
Yeah,
they did.
I got a great relationship with them and,
and uh,
and I,
I'm one of those guys that,
you know,
I have a hard time being objective sometimes about it,
although I try not to,
you know,
uh,
look through rose colored glasses every time.
You know,
I'm talking about operations and things that they're doing,
but I had a great time and I got a lot of respect for the people there.
And so when I got ready to leave and I left for a pretty simple reason,
I've got a daughter who's in college.
Terrific,
terrific kid.
Um,
and I was just never home when she was growing up.
And so we got to a certain point where I didn't have a choice,
I had to be home.
And so,
um,
I,
I walked in and I was overseas at the time and I walked into my,
uh,
my,
my boss who was very senior,
um,
in the operations group and I said,
I think it's time to leave.
And he said,
what are you gonna do?
You can't,
you can't leave,
you know,
and to just stick around.
And he knew I was getting antsy and,
and he said,
God,
stick around it,
you know,
it's gonna get better.
Cause we had gotten a little bit risk averse at that point and it gets a little
wearing after a while to be working on operations.
And then all of a sudden at the,
at the last minute people say,
no,
we can't do that too much.
Blow back.
And then you pull back and think,
well what the fuck was out all about?
Like what kind of risk or risk of her can you talk about operations?
Yeah,
I mean a lot of times it's,
it's just political blowback concern over what a host country might say.
If,
if,
if something went south,
yeah.
If,
you know,
if something went south,
if you're operating in another country and something you're about to do,
uh,
you know,
blows up on you.
And then the political blowback from country to country dealing with that.
And so that oftentimes as a sort of thing that people think about.
But anyway,
so,
so this guy,
a great,
great,
great character,
um,
and terrific experience,
uh,
with the agency.
He said,
stick around.
So anyway,
long story short,
I went back to,
uh,
to Virginia,
resigned,
um,
to,
uh,
to start a business.
And,
um,
uh,
woke up the next morning and the guy had said,
you're going to feel terrible if you do this.
If you go back and you're resigned,
you're going to feel terrible when you wake up.
And so I woke up and I felt pretty damn good.
So,
so I called him overseas.
It was towards the end of the day of his time.
And I said,
I gotta tell you I'd feel great.
And he said,
I want a dick.
And so,
uh,
but he's gotten out since he's retired and now he's in business and we get
together a lot and he says,
yeah,
some of the worst advice ever gave anybody,
but it was it,
you know,
it was uh,
it was,
it was not easy leaving because you know,
you have a huge amount of respect,
you spend a lot of time,
you know,
in there and you're doing things,
um,
that,
you know,
sometimes you're doing things that you know,
nobody else is doing.
There's nobody else doing this right now.
I remember having that feeling of walking away from something and thinking
that's it.
I'm the only person that's just done this right now.
And it's pretty,
it's pretty special thing.
And that's kind of,
they draw you in that way because you know the of the challenge and the
patriotism and all the rest of it and that's exactly how it should be.
You know,
nobody does it for the money.
That's for sure.
If there is one bit of controversy or that the main controversy,
the main conspiracy when it comes to the CIA,
it's drugs and the main evil conspiracy is that the CIA was involved in selling
drugs and African American communities to fund foreign wars.
The contras in Nicaragua,
you know the whole thing with Oliver North,
you know,
with uh,
freeway,
Ricky Ross,
the guy who is out now,
he was involved directly with selling drugs.
The money went straight to the CIA.
The CIA used that money.
You're shaking your head.
Get my head.
Yeah,
you don't believe it.
Now look,
I,
I spent a long enough time behind the curtain and,
and I met Chris.
What,
what are people going to,
if people who are down that road are going to be listening to this guy to go
with a five course,
he's going to say that.
I mean,
what else is he going to say?
But honest to God,
I'd,
I'd spend enough time behind the curtain,
um,
in a,
in operations the whole time to say that we've got a lot of restrictions on us
in terms of what we can do,
who we can deal with and what you're able to accomplish.
And um,
yeah,
the,
the whole concept of the drug thing.
I don't know when that got started.
I don't know how it sort of popped up initially,
but it takes on a life of its own,
like everything else,
like theories about the Kennedy assassination like we were talking about.
Um,
and you're never going to let him go away and sometimes saying that,
you know,
if I sit here and protests,
people going to say,
well of course they must be true because he's protests.
Is it possible the things went on that you don't know about?
Oh,
absolutely not.
How would that happen?
No,
of course there is.
Yeah.
But,
but at the same time,
yeah.
But at the same time,
I will say this much,
uh,
people can't keep their Yap shut will over a period of tiles is,
I'm sorry,
what?
No.
Barry Seal's is very seals like dead now,
but Barry seal was,
he was a fighter who was a pilot rather,
and a,
a drug smuggler.
And he said that he flew covert flights for the Central Intelligence Agency must
be limited.
Eat.
Well,
he's dead now.
He died.
He was assassinated when he was on his way to testify with George Bush phone
number in his pocket.
That's the Salacious d test,
that details,
and that's got to be true,
right?
He had photographs with a CIA agents and met a gene cartel officers.
I mean,
he without a doubt was a drug runner.
The question is whether he was actually running drugs for the CIA.
Yeah.
I feel comfortable being here and saying,
no,
of course you got to say that.
But also,
I mean,
and again,
you're right.
The more times I say it,
people didn't go well ski.
It's gotta be true because he's saying it so often.
Um,
but I,
you know,
I,
uh,
the agency is,
is operated by humans just like everything else.
And so it's never going to be perfect.
It's never gonna be perfect.
There will be a slip ups,
Iran Contra,
you know,
um,
the whole decision to nation build in Iraq and what that meant.
Although the agency,
you know,
it doesn't drive policy,
so I'm not sure what,
what,
what?
That's good.
Well the Iran Contra thing is directly connected to selling drugs in poor
neighborhoods in la.
Yeah,
but freeway,
Ricky Ross like literally sold hundreds of millions of dollars for the drugs,
but not for the agency.
Well he says that that's how he got a hold of the drugs
to the agency.
Yeah.
But that's,
I guess that's my point.
If I'm,
if I'm a dirt bag,
yeah.
What am I going to do?
I'm going to complicate things and muddy the waters because I'm going to say,
well my God,
I did it
for the government.
I did it either for the ACA,
didn't have read partial.
I did it for the secret service freeway.
Ricky Ross didn't even realize he was selling drugs for the CIA until he was in
jail.
He didn't know who the connections war that he was getting.
What's interesting about Barry Seal,
the guy who died is that he was an informant for the DEA,
the DEA,
as you were talking about,
the CIA and the FBI have like a little combative relationship.
So to the DEA and the CIA,
there's all sorts of interagency.
I worked with the DEA overseas and,
and uh,
in counter narcotics operations.
And again,
yeah,
I mean,
part of it is,
is,
uh,
going back to the same thing we talked about with the bureau relationships
during those early days,
starting out,
working with them overseas,
there was a lot of kind of p and on each other's turf relationship is much
better now.
But I guess all I'm saying is,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll leave it at that,
is that the agency
was not in the business of selling drugs.
If we wanted money to fund operations,
we had other recourses day to gather that money rather than narcotics and
selling drugs to a lower income neighborhoods in the United States of America.
I just,
it's just to me,
I understand you're never going to shift people off a certain position and
people are going to believe what they're going to believe.
But,
um,
it kind of goes back to what I said at the very beginning.
The number one misconception is that this agency is at the fuck people over.
Yeah.
This,
this Barry seal one is a very interesting one because he had so much information
about the CIA and so much information about the Medellin cartel and drug dealing
in the first place.
What he had actually said led people to believe that he was a guy who is very
knowledgeable about the actual operations.
It's the number one piece of evidence that points to the CIA.
And then w what happened with Michael Rupert,
Michael [inaudible],
who was a former La narcotics officer of busted people and he,
do you know what Mike,
you've been down every rabbit hole there.
He's got to say,
man,
you,
you've been spending a lot of time down the rabbit,
Warren.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
again,
uh,
we're,
we're going to just be at loggerheads at it
on this one because I,
you know,
I keep going back to the same thing.
I understand why,
why people find it interesting.
I don't understand why people believe,
okay,
I'm going to,
this is what I'm going to choose to believe.
Uh,
I got a different perspective based on a lot of life experience inside the
organization.
And if I saw a shit that I thought was absolutely,
you know,
tenable,
then yeah,
I'd like to think I'm a decent enough person and I don't have a dog in the hunt.
I'm not bound by anything other than a respect for the organization based on the
experience I've had with them.
So anyway,
but that's exactly what people would actually
take me to say.
Well,
the guy who was the head of the CIA,
the director of Central Intelligence Agency in [inaudible] 96 was Don John
Deutch.
That's how you say his name,
Deutsche.
Uh,
he was,
uh,
in Los Angeles.
He was at a town hall meeting,
and Michael Rupert,
who was a former La narcotics officer who was an officer at the time,
confronted him saying that in his experience as an LAPD narcotics officer,
he had seen evidence of the CIA complicity and drug dealing and the
confrontation was handled so poorly by doors.
It resulted in him being terminated from the CIA.
Did resulted in Deutsche Bank Terminator?
No.
Why was he terminated?
Wow.
Because he was a,
this wasn't good.
It just wasn't good.
He was acknowledged along with Stansfield Turner and a couple of others of being
not our most,
uh,
effective,
beloved directors.
You know,
that's not,
I don't want to besmirch anybody's character,
but at the same time,
the idea that,
wow,
what was,
it was on television,
but it was in Glasgow as a director.
No.
You ever seen the video of Rupert confronting him?
Uh,
no I haven't,
but I,
I've,
I've watched it.
I've dealt with John Deutch.
I've been there when John Deutch was there.
Now,
eh?
Nah,
mean,
you know,
you always have favorites.
It's like anything else.
I have my favorite boss at the company or I got my favorite and you know,
I've got my favorite directors for sure.
It's your favorite podcaster.
Oh,
it's gotta be this Rogan Guy.
I mean it's coffees outstanding and uh,
yeah,
but no,
it's,
it's uh,
it,
it is what it is.
I mean I played this one thing for you and then we'll let it go.
But
Rupert Confronting John Doyle,
pull that,
pull this up Jamie.
Cause it's pretty fascinating.
Wash this and okay.
This is when I will tell you director Deutsch as a former Los Angeles police,
narcotics detective,
that the agency has dealt drugs throughout this country for sure.
People are clapping.
So it must be true.
It must be true.
Yeah.
It's a crowd pleasing statement.
My hobby has weighed.
That is an answer for a lot of you.
Enough.
Can you please,
I refer now.
I referred her.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
This chick's not good at her job.
No.
Wait a minute.
What's going on here?
Please leave now.
That's a good way to
get a Mcdonald's here.
What's going on by the CIA?
Narcotics booth on your way out.
Pick up your coat now.
We'll come back to you as we roll back across to the center section.
Yeah,
director of Deutsche.
I will refer you to three specific agency operations known as Amadeus,
Pegasus and watchtower.
I know my own ass documents heavily redacted by the agency.
I was personally exposed to CIA operations and recruited by CIA personnel who
attempted to recruit me in the late seventies to become involved in protecting
agency drunk operations in this country.
I had been trying to get this out for 18 years and I have the evidence.
My question,
if he was very specific,
sir.
If in the course of the igs investigations and Fred hits his work,
you'll come across evidence of severely criminal activity and it's classified.
Well,
you use that classification to hide the criminal activity or will you tell the
American people the truth?
[inaudible]
why did you want to hear the response first from Julian tax on that then from
the director,
right?
Why
from your,
I'm sorry,
z.
You could pause it here.
He basically said what he needed to say.
Yeah.
So what do you think?
That kind of shit,
that's the first guy who ever claimed it,
had been tried to be recruited by the Seattle.
He's a la narcotics officer.
I mean,
he's a legitimate guy.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Okay.
That's,
that's I,
I look at it and I see the same thing I see in,
in,
uh,
a lot of other cases.
You have sort of a,
a delusion thing going on at delusion of grandeur.
You've got sort of,
we see it all the time in,
in guys like,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not putting them in the same category,
don't get me wrong.
But guys like Hanson,
guys like Jim Nicholson,
uh,
ed Lee,
Howard,
all these things,
people never listen to me.
If they just listened to me,
things would have been better.
So therefore the man's out to fuck me,
therefore I'm going to fuck the man.
And that's typically in the agency,
has a,
is a beautiful shining light up there on,
on the hill to take a shot at because it's so intriguing.
Nobody fights back.
That's one of the reasons why the agency is always getting kicked in the ass up
on Capitol Hill.
We don't,
we don't push back because we're not,
you're not in a position to,
what are you going to go,
go back up there and start talking about twice methods again,
getting back to this guy,
uh,
yeah,
I hold absolutely no credibility in it.
I can guarantee you that Deutsche was not let go because of his response or lack
thereof to,
uh,
that,
particular rant.
So,
but it doesn't,
I'm going to sit here.
It's just like me saying this is how Kennedy was killed.
It's not gonna make any difference.
So everyone's going to believe what they're going to believe.
Again,
I go back to the same thing.
Somebody pushing that Theiri as their own life experience.
I've got a life experience,
which you,
I was fortunate enough,
gave me access inside an organization that I,
you know,
that I think gave me an understanding as to how they operate and the ethics with
which they have,
even though people say ethics,
the agency,
I mean,
again,
as an example,
people,
people went nuts over the interrogation thing.
If you mean the waterboarding,
waterboarding stuff.
If anybody had taken the time,
all those critics who were taking the time to read the Dlj memos that,
uh,
holders,
the Justice Department,
uh,
decided we were great to release,
then they,
you can't not come away from reading seriously the DOJ memos and not say,
well,
shit,
every little thing,
they were going back and forth trying to see is this appropriate?
Can we do this?
Can we can't do that?
Okay,
can we do this?
can I,
uh,
push him against a fake wall?
All I can't,
can I do the following?
And there's back and forth and back and forth and back and forth.
And it belies as a notion that somehow we just out there fucking over the world
and acting like a bunch of cowboys.
Um,
so,
but again,
you know,
it's,
it's like the agency going up on Capitol Hill and trying to defend itself.
It,
what are you going to do?
People are going to believe what they believe.
What if I was going to give you advice though in the future?
I mean,
obviously you don't need my advice when someone brings up something,
even if it's ridiculous.
Don't laugh while you discredit it because it makes it look like a bullshit.
And you know,
like when people do that,
they go off.
That's ridiculous.
No,
I know.
And I think you're right.
I think you're right.
But what you will,
but you also have to,
you also have to realize that it is ridiculous.
It is ridiculous to me.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to react the way it's natural for me to read rogue agents that were
involved.
I mean,
we see it all the time when narcotics officers,
that's a big thing with narcotics officers.
They get involved,
they go undercover,
they start selling drugs,
they start doing drugs and then they say,
you know what?
These motherfuckers are making millions of dollars.
I'm going to make it a little piece on the side for myself.
Put it away somewhere in a safe deposit box,
live off of it or whatever.
I mean,
it does happen.
People do get corrupted.
Yeah,
of course people get
corrupted.
I don't,
back to your point,
was I the director of the agency?
No.
So do I know everything that goes on?
What am I saying?
I'm saying based on my experience,
based on a lot of time behind the curtain and and working in a lot of
operational environments and dealing with a lot of people over 17 years,
uh,
no.
To me,
I,
I don't buy,
it doesn't make any sense.
I don't believe it.
But you know,
again,
I got to leave it at that because you know,
a,
anything in this world as possible.
I don't believe it's possible.
I,
but that's exactly what people expect me to say.
I keep going back to that same force.
Is there a no always an issue as well with in order to adequately protect the
United States interests in order to adequately act in secrecy in the interest of
the United States,
people in government,
you kind of,
there's,
there's always going to be like walls that people come up against where to do
your job.
I would imagine if you're involved in something that requires a certain amount
of secrecy,
it can't discuss certain things.
So when things come along,
when Congress wants to have answers to questions like,
do you know what the Glo Mar,
you know what Glo Mar is like a Glo Mar response global marine.
Do you remember when that Russian submarine?
Yeah,
there was a Russian submarine that the United States was trying to recover as a
nuclear submarine and um,
Global Marine was a company that was trying to pull this down.
Yeah,
it was a great operation.
They were trying to pull this thing out of the ocean,
but it was an incredible operation by miles deep.
There's millions of pounds of metal and they had to pull this nuclear sub up and
they were trying to get all this information about the capabilities of these
Russian subs.
What,
you know,
what kind of,
um,
documents were on board and it was right after Watergate.
So because there was so much,
so much blow back against secrecy because of Watergate,
because everybody had assumed that the United States will now we find out that
Nixon was spying on people and he's kicked out of office.
So the global marine response to this was we can neither confirm nor deny,
and that's where that term came from.
We can neither confirm nor deny it came out of them having to come up with some
sort of response because the freedom of Information Act,
they required them to do so.
So they came up with this way to respond but not responding.
Does anybody do any good because it came out in the press anyway,
eventually.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It did.
Yeah.
Pretty quickly.
But
doesn't that kind of highlight like how difficult it is?
I mean,
look,
this is it.
That's a perfect example.
You're dealing with a Russian submarines during the Cold War.
We're,
we're worried we're going to go to war with Russia.
If we,
you know,
who the f w why do we have to tell you if we found a fucking Russian sub that's
got nuclear missiles,
then it,
well,
why should we have to tell the American people and also informed the Soviet
Union and then they go and find out where we're doing this and then they find
out that we have their sub,
it fucks up everything.
Right,
right.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
decade after decade,
it becomes,
it becomes less likely that the government's going to keep deep secrets.
Right.
Because it just,
the way information flows and,
and the access to information and with the Internet and just also this does
general inability anymore of officials to,
to keep their Yap shut.
So,
you know,
I mean,
you look at,
look at Fdr for crying out loud,
depressive great.
Uh,
you know,
not say anything about his in his,
uh,
his handicap,
you know,
and,
and so for several years it was just,
that was kept under wraps.
You can't do that if you're not going to do that anymore.
I mean,
and,
and so you look at this and you think,
well,
yeah,
I mean we can't,
the idea that the government,
and that's a good thing.
And in a sense of good idea that the government's going to keep,
you know,
big secrets from people.
There's a tendency to just talk.
I mean,
for crying out loud,
the New York Times,
half the time the front page is made up of,
of,
you know,
front page stories with nothing but anonymous sources and they can't be quoted
or they can't be identified because we're not supposed to talk about it.
Well then don't fucking talk about it.
If you've signed agreement,
if you signed a deal that says you're not going to talk about something,
you know,
shut your pie hole,
or if you feel that strongly about it,
get the fuck out and then talk about it.
What do you,
how do you feel about guys like Edward Snowden guys?
Yeah.
Funny.
It's funny.
See,
I laugh when I get irritated.
He irritating.
Yeah,
he's irritating.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
again,
uh,
you know,
everyone's going to disagree over this.
I'm a small government person,
so I agree that you got to have checks and balances and I believe a,
a handful of things.
One of them being is that,
and people aren't going to believe this because they watched a lot of movies and
beach books and shit and they done a lot of rabbit holes,
but the u s intel communities the most transparent until community on the
planet,
right?
Maybe that sets the bar pretty low compared to other services,
That's saying like,
you're the nicest rapist.
Exactly.
She's your great stalker.
Um,
and uh,
so I think that it's,
it's,
um,
for me
the idea that a,
that Snowden had,
um,
signed agreements and then chose to do what he did,
disappeared into,
uh,
into the PRC and then now is over in Russia.
Um,
and despite people wanting to wave the flag and saying he's a hero,
uh,
on a certain level,
it's caused a great deal of damage.
And I think that gift,
he was that distraught over this.
Then there were other avenues that he could have pursued to,
um,
to bring this to light.
And I think that what he's done is very damaging.
I understand why people,
you know,
beat the drum for him.
I get that.
Um,
again,
my opinion is based on certain life experiences.
So,
you know,
we're never gonna meet in the middle on this one.
The importance of secrecy,
as long those losses into your word and what the sort of damage does it,
some of this information actually does out in the field in terms of,
of,
of what that means.
Um,
and so yeah,
I,
again,
I'm kind of conflicted in a way because I agree.
You gotta you gotta keep things in check,
you know,
and you got to end and you've got to have the ability to understand what the
government is doing in this regard.
Um,
I think that the best way to do that has had a very,
um,
inquisitive and proactive,
political base.
Congress and Senate should do their jobs.
And part of it is,
you know,
there's a game that goes on in Washington where every time something like this
comes out and it's politically expedient for them to do so,
they express outrage and Angst and Oh my God,
I can't believe this is happening.
And there's a well worn path between the Intel community and Capitol Hill with
people going up in briefing these people all the time on the lunch Snowden's
case,
what he's talking about is them spying on every single American.
That's essentially what it is.
Yeah.
Don't you think that people have a right to privacy if they're just innocent
folks that a tax payers and they're not breaking the law,
they're not doing anything.
I think that there's a there,
there is that and I don't disagree with,
that's why Sam conflicted on,
on the,
on the whole issue.
I'm conflicted as well
because he did actually pursue different avenues before he released everything.
What he says,
he says he did.
He said he believe them.
No,
there's a lot of characteristics of snow and that remind me of again,
of some of the other characters in an account intelligence,
a world that we dealt with that um,
uh,
I don't take everything to say it,
just like this character that we watched on the,
on the video,
just like a rubric.
Yeah.
I don't take what they say,
you know,
for face value now because you're willing to do a certain thing then that makes
me question your,
um,
your,
your sort of your compass and so,
but,
but yeah,
I,
the idea that,
uh,
you know,
the government's collecting metadata now admittedly I could drive a big fucking
truck load of Metadata,
dump it here on our table and you wouldn't know if shit,
but it's,
oh,
it's,
you know,
then again,
you look at Amazon and Google and you look what they're doing.
Yeah.
But he was saying that people were actually going into people's emails,
extracting naked photographs,
passing them around the office,
Edward Snowden sitting that I,
again,
we're gonna have to fall down on that.
This,
this whole thing that I don't believe him saying that all the time.
I was involved in things.
I never saw behavior like that.
And we dealt with NSA a fair amount and on the technical collection side,
right.
So,
but at the same time,
I understand,
you know,
people are gonna believe a different thing.
I think it's important for us to have these conversations.
I think it's important for us to keep the government in check.
I just think this is,
I disagree with the way that he went about doing it.
I guess that's,
that's the best thing.
But I don't disagree with,
with the fact that it's an important conversation.
I think you felt like you had no recourse.
Well,
yeah.
I mean that's sort of the Hansen when he started spying for the fucking Soviets.
So that's always the case.
I didn't have any other choice.
People weren't listening to me.
Oh my God,
you know,
I'm not getting the respect I deserve.
This is funny.
They all go to the Soviets,
right?
He's right over there chilling and Russia and they've got everything.
He's Guy Glenn Greenwald and,
and,
and Snowden.
He's got to say,
they only want to talk about how,
no,
we've,
we've safeguarded,
well,
if they're smarter than the fucking PRC and the pla out in China and smarter
than,
than the FSB and in Russia,
then you know,
when get monkeys on Unicorns are going to fly out my ass.
So I just not buying it.
You,
you mean terms of safeguard,
safeguard in there very important secret information,
intelligence perspective,
all that shit that he's walked out the door with.
His is in the hands of the,
of,
uh,
people who don't have our interests at heart.
Hard
meaning not just what's been released to the concerns about the American people,
about privacy,
but some other stuff that is totally unrelated to privacy that is very
important.
But yeah,
that,
well,
that can't be argued in my opinion,
that that's very tricky.
I mean if,
if that is the case and the data isn't secure and it can compromise people in
the field and all sorts of other things,
but what Americans,
their number one concern was that this is what is an ongoing situation like this
and the NSA,
uh,
the facility that they're building in Utah,
we're going to store all the bay center.
Yeah.
It scares the shit out of people that every single phone call they make is being
stored somewhere.
Every single email,
every single text message everyone pick they send.
Yeah.
And,
and I think that,
you know,
there again,
there's,
there's ways to go about,
um,
this ways to go,
but we're supposed to have checks and balances
place.
No one even knew about this until this guy came up.
I also don't necessarily buy that one either.
Um,
the CIA improperly hacked into Senate computers.
Yeah.
That one is a,
you've got to kind of reverse engineer that story.
Um,
they had set up a shared network system between the Senate staffers who were
busy writing what took them over five years and they had a preset agenda on,
on,
uh,
the interrogation history of interrogation by the agency.
So it took them over five years to write.
But during the course of that,
they set up a shared network,
shared system,
uh,
for the agency and the Senate staffers who were writing this thing to use.
So,
uh,
at a certain point,
it became clear through
the course of that process,
that Senate stablish head,
uh,
acquired,
documentation that they weren't supposed to have that was above that.
They're,
uh,
parameters,
the classification,
how they get it.
That is what then what happened was on this shared system,
not in the Senate computer system,
nobody in the Senate is arguing that it's a shared network that was set up
specifically for this process of sharing documents.
So,
uh,
the agency ran what is basically a forensic,
effort,
a keyword and phrase search happens every day.
I've got a company diligence for all your information and security needs that,
you know,
we've got a computer forensics group.
So keyword phrase searches is a standard forensic tool.
So they went through that to try to figure out how did this document and did
others go walk about.
So that's what that whole,
uh,
who ha was about.
But again,
it's,
it points to even that level,
even with a Senate Intel Committee where,
which,
you know,
um,
uh,
again they've got the ability if they would use it,
if they would stay inquisitive,
if they would stay a proactive,
uh,
they've got the ability to pursue things.
But there's a level of,
of,
uh,
of distrust sometimes it goes on and it kind of comes back around to this whole
transparency issue.
Um,
you know,
conspiracy,
I don't know,
there's,
there's always been an,
I keep going back to that same thing.
You asked me that question at the very beginning,
which was terrific.
Which,
you know,
what's the number one misconception?
Oh,
the agencies at the fuck.
So also your take on,
it was just at the CIA,
was trying to figure out how the Senate acquire these documents that they were
not supposed to be in the point of their exercise as well
as like from a counterintelligence perspective,
you then you have to start figuring out what else has walked out the door and
what the Senate interpreted it as.
Was that,
I guess the agency was pushing back and in an attempt to,
um,
what,
I dunno,
stop the reporting or the reporting had already gone out this route,
this massive report that they've already written had gone out.
You'd already gone out to the community for,
for review.
Uh,
he'd gone to the White House for review.
So it's not as if they were going to try to stop that flow of information.
They've already done that.
They've already released it.
Well,
they haven't released it to the,
to the,
uh,
the public because they're now the waiting from the White House for a review.
So,
I dunno,
uh,
you know,
Eh,
there's
the agency has a long history of,
uh,
of being a lightening rod for things because of the nature of its business.
And that's understood.
People work inside the organization understand that.
And,
and,
and I'm outside.
It's why I can express a frustration,
but I guarantee you when you're inside and you're constantly being thrown out
there as you know,
uh,
an evil cabal or selling drugs to a low income neighborhoods or fucking over,
you know,
everybody else are doing,
working against the interests as opposed to White House delivers tasking and
says,
get this done.
And the job of the agency has to march forward regardless of who's in the
administration.
And it doesn't matter whether it's President Obama or President Bush,
President Clinton,
President Carter,
doesn't matter.
They give you the tasking,
you'd do it.
So when you see a situation like this,
we're,
Dianne Feinstein says that the CIA may have violated the constitution.
And do you think there's a lot of political grandstanding going on?
Grants and a,
there is,
yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I mean it political,
grand standing and everything that goes on nowadays.
I mean it's,
it doesn't really matter what he's big speeches.
It's like to set them up in a position where it looks like they're looking out
for the American public.
When in reality,
if they looked at the actual circumstances and the actual facts behind what had
gone on,
it would have been far less.
Or if in other cases
are they were,
they were expressing,
oh my God,
I can't believe this interrogation program is doing this.
Well,
fuck that.
We've got briefers it,
like I said,
March,
back and forth and back and forth and,
and,
and explain what's going on and answer questions.
I mean,
the agencies if from the Church Committee on and,
and even prior to that,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's a long history of,
of sort of this,
this game that goes on.
If I'm a politician up on Capitol Hill and I get,
and I see that this is not going to look good from my constituency back home,
then I'm going to express surprise.
Even if I sat on that Intel Committee and listened to what was going on,
it was supposedly listening to what was going on.
So I,
again,
I'm not saying that it probably won't,
but I'm not saying the fucking agencies.
Perfect.
And again,
I'm also not saying I can be objective about it and that would be,
I'd be lying if I said that I'm,
I am subjective.
I got a great deal of respect for him.
My experiences with them were extremely positive.
I saw people stand up with really sound moral compass and always try to do the
right thing.
Um,
so that's what I took away from it.
That's how I,
I then processed all this other crap that's out there is noise.
So,
you know,
if I'm wrong and I die and I find I'm wrong,
fuck me.
I don't know what to say.
That's one way to look at it.
I can't imagine that it's possible to know everything that's going on in any
organization.
I mean,
you can't,
no matter what it is,
if it's a police department or if it's a,
the CIA or the FBI or the United States army,
every general doesn't know about every single action that every single soldier
is involved in this.
It's impossible.
It's like going out to President Obama every time something goes wrong,
right?
I don't necessarily mean,
yeah,
it's,
it's convenient.
Um,
but no,
no president,
whether it's him or this President Bush,
or whether it's President Clinton,
whoever,
uh,
you can't know everything.
You gotta,
you gotta try,
do your best to make sure you don't get surprised.
And then for that you've got to rely on your,
on your staff.
And I don't think saying that you were surprised and,
and you're just finding out about it.
It's a good strategy necessarily.
Uh,
but at the same time,
you can't be expected to know everything.
Do you feel like that what's going on?
Like the Wiki leaks thing and the artist formerly known as Bradley Manning,
now Chelsea Manning,
Chelsea man,
you have to say Chelsea,
um,
her,
uh,
do you,
do you feel like that's in the same league as Edward Snowden?
Is one better in one worst because one was a soldier?
No,
you're,
that's a really,
it's a really good question.
Um,
I,
you know what?
Nobody ever accused me of being a deep thinker.
So my,
my feeling about it is the commonality there is that you,
you initially agreed to,
um,
keep your mouth shut,
to protect the information that you were given responsibility for having access
to and to do your,
your,
your job.
Um,
I think if you sign up to commitments,
if you make a promise,
if you sign that promise,
that contract,
then you got to stick with it.
And,
uh,
and if you,
if you decide at some point that you can't because you're just so fucking
morally opposed to it,
then you know,
man up and find a way to do it properly.
Don't,
uh,
don't,
don't break the fucking law.
Don't go to the Soviets or the Russians call them the Soviet still.
Yeah.
I don't go to the Russians,
don't go to the Chinese,
don't,
you know,
don't go to,
are those people who again,
don't have our interests in heart and uh,
and try to claim that you're doing it for the good of,
of all mankind.
You know,
that doesn't make any sense.
What do you think they could do though?
I mean,
what does someone do if they feel like they're being ignored and they're on the
inside and they,
they honestly feel like some horrible things are happening and they have no
worries
of course.
Well,
you know what,
it's,
uh,
if you,
if you believe in the justice system,
who knows what,
you know,
what am,
I can't kids if they
yourself in this position at home,
he's a guy like Julian Assange's songs,
cause he's not even an American,
you know,
he's,
he's locked up in jail and he's in an embassy supposedly for,
yeah.
I thought it was coming out though the,
I thought it
was last I heard he was,
he was coming out to,
to face the charges of the,
of the sexual assault.
Well,
he started it.
He's not doing well health wise.
It's not good.
Did Not have any sun for two fucking years.
I've been at embassies.
I wouldn't want to spend two years in there.
Um,
but I,
I think it's,
it's um,
you know what again,
I easy I guess easy to say when you're not in that position,
but at the same time,
um,
again,
it's just my opinion,
you know,
don't,
don't fucking break your covenants,
don't break the law.
Um,
find a way to,
to,
to do it.
And if you can,
and if you can't just deal with us,
deal with it.
Walk out and got to leave.
Go find yourself something else to do.
Okay.
Yourself a job that you can be happy with,
you know,
but you know,
I'm sure there's people out there right now screaming,
oh my God,
well you got to bring it up.
Well then fine level though.
What level can the crimes be?
I mean,
what if you found out,
like,
let's get,
let's go deep.
Like what if you found out that there was some sort of a false flag operation
that was going to result in the death of a bunch of American lives,
including American servicemen and cleaning American Pete,
you know,
officers and enlisted folks.
I mean,
if you found out something along those lines,
well that's a,
that's a,
that's a thriller movie concept.
But yeah,
and there's never that ticking time bombs scenario.
I mean,
by the way,
that's,
that was never a good defensive of sort of like a,
the interrogation program,
that ticking time bomb,
you know,
that always saying,
well,
if I've got five seconds,
so therefore I've got to hit this guy over the head with a car battery.
Um,
but um,
you almost always have more than five seconds.
Um,
but um,
but in that sort of a scenario,
I mean,
that is a crime against the United States.
You,
yeah,
then fine,
go out there and it's not as if,
you know,
again,
it's a hypothetical.
It doesn't make any sense in the sense,
in a sense that,
what am I gonna do?
I'm worried that I'm going to go and I'm going to tell my superiors and it's all
a cabal and they're all working together and the whole organization's gonna
suddenly and now I'm the one who's going to be fucked.
And the next thing I know I'm being chased in the basement of the organization
by all these people.
And it's a cabal.
No,
I mean,
you know,
if you find out that,
that there's something,
there's one thing to say,
I,
you know,
I haven't seen any indication of,
of a,
of breaking the law,
but morally,
I dunno,
this bothers me.
That's different.
If you find it,
you know,
then,
okay,
then that's one case you've got to deal with.
If you find a case where there's something he labelled one,
I'm willing,
fine,
probably bring it to light immediately.
There's no other choice.
I mean,
it's like,
I used to tell them like,
guys,
you know,
you make a mistake,
you do something wrong.
You tell me immediately and we'll,
and,
and you know,
that's the way that you resolve problems.
That's how you fix things.
That's how you make sure that,
that,
that things don't go off the rails and the agency does operate under that,
you know,
again,
people aren't going to buy it.
But,
you know,
I saw time and time again,
somebody would make a mistakes and we would make a bad decision and,
and the first thing they would did was a march in there and tell them their
supervisors,
chief of station of whoever it was.
And you know,
there,
there's,
there's that type of culture in there.
Again,
people aren't gonna buy it.
I mean,
cause that's the whole issue that the artist formerly known as Bradley Manning
faced is that there was nothing that he could do or she could do now that was
being taken seriously.
So she went public with all that information because no one was listening.
Well,
they have,
uh,
yeah,
they have,
uh,
Igg,
office jag office had a lot of avenues that they can go to that wouldn't be
walking into your immediate supervisor in the military.
Um,
because yeah,
sure,
maybe that's not the best thing to do.
Maybe you're concerned.
It's all,
you know,
I,
I'm going to be punished for stepping out of line.
Well,
they have practices in place that you go to just like in a corporate
corporation,
got a compliance officer's,
you gotta,
you know,
Ombudsmen,
whatever you wanna call it.
So I had a,
I dunno,
I again,
I,
you know,
I'm not smart enough to,
to,
uh,
be able to address issues like that.
But,
um,
I do think if you make promises and you,
you agree to,
uh,
to protect and serve the interest of the United States,
um,
don't break the fucking law.
Don't break your oath.
That's,
you're right.
Don't break your mouth that this is what you're dealing with when you're dealing
with any agency or the military.
You're dealing with,
uh,
a group that you've agreed to be a part of.
It's a sacred oath that you've taken.
It's very important that you keep that oath and isn't what we're seeing with all
these leaks and all this different stuff.
Sort of a,
it's,
it's also,
it's an excellent example of the,
the Times that we live in that is when you're dealing with something so
sensitive and so difficult,
it's very,
it's very hard to get people to just keep their mouth shut now.
Right?
And no,
that's it.
And they used to be able to hide these things.
That's a really good point.
A part of it is,
again,
part of his,
all the anonymous quotes in,
uh,
in,
in the newspapers and oftentimes attributed to his senior military officials,
senior administration officials.
Part of it is the books that get written,
you know,
the sort of the,
um,
the idea that I'm going to finish up as chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and I'm gonna write a book,
you know,
and that,
that filters down to the,
to the,
uh,
you know,
the junior officers,
they see that other people in the,
in the organizations,
and they see that and they think,
well,
what the hell?
What's,
what's sacred?
Then you know,
you're going to get out after 30 years and you get to talk about all the,
you know,
the various things that were done in and give a mia culpa over a couple of
things and you're going to talk about shit that,
you know,
all that time you knew you weren't supposed to talk about.
So it's,
um,
yeah,
I think there was a,
there's a,
there's a slide there in the,
in the sort of the cultural understanding of what is and isn't
acceptable.
So will you,
you're talking to about,
you keep saying the New York Times and you're talking about,
uh,
unnamed quotes and unnamed sources.
You're talking about this James Rise in case where this guy is detailing a bosh
CIA operation in Iran and they're trying to,
uh,
trying to get his sources.
Well,
no,
it didn't,
not,
not just that you can't swing a dead cat,
um,
most days without hitting a major newspaper that's dealing with anonymous
sources.
I mean they just,
you know,
it's,
I'm just talking about in terms of all the general,
uh,
use of,
I mean,
remember that I don't think you could in the past,
I don't think you could write a,
uh,
a major story if you had more than one anonymous source,
maybe couldn't even have an source.
But now it's
just,
it's an accepted fact.
And I guess the point being is that people just feel more comfortable speaking
out of turn and that filters down to all the younger members of whatever
organization it may be,
whether it's a company,
whether it's a hedge fund,
whether it's a,
the agency at military,
whatever it may be.
So you feel like in the case of this rising guy who's,
he's in deep shit,
right?
I mean,
he's,
the Supreme Court just rejected his appeal.
Um,
his refusal to,
uh,
identify a source and what he's done is write a book based on some information
that allegedly someone from the CIA gave him,
the Supreme Court saying,
look,
you've got to give up that information.
You've got to say,
who told you this stuff?
Because that's more important than the freedom of the press,
right.
Protection of the,
of the source.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Again,
you know,
um,
I don't even know where to go with that.
That's like a,
that's like one of those meet the press sort of issues that no one's ever going
to call me on hold.
To play devil's advocate,
one way to look at it as,
it's not like New York Times reporters had been infallible.
It's not like they haven't been accused of plagiarism.
It's not like they haven't bullshitted before.
And if this guy wrote a book and the book was based on
unfactual
or either lies or fabricated information,
it is possible.
Is it possible that you could meet behind closed doors and do that or it doesn't
have to go public?
Well,
you would think so.
Right?
I mean the judges,
it can't be the first time they'd need to find a mechanism for something like
this.
You know,
just like with,
with testimony up on the hill,
Capitol Hill,
I mean,
it's not,
it's never the first time any of that crap happens.
So they must have some sort of protocol in place,
you would think.
Um,
but perhaps there's a political element here to,
you know,
beating it out in public.
I don't know.
It is a very interesting situation when it comes to protecting sources.
It's like it's,
it would almost be if we had a lie detector tests,
like an infallible lie detector test where you can say,
did these sources actually tell you this information where these sources really
CIA deep undercover operatives where they legit people and you know,
and then the guy,
it turns out he's lying.
Well then you throw the book at them.
Yet if he's telling the truth,
then it seems like the onus is almost on the CIA.
Well,
yeah.
Um,
although I wouldn't put a lot of,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean not to get,
not to get in the weeds,
but yeah,
the polygraph is not necessarily,
it's,
it's a,
it's an art.
It's not a science.
It's not ready yet.
This is sort of a battle between the idea of protecting sources and the idea of
protecting America,
that these two things,
maybe the oath that a person takes is equally important as the laws that are in
place to protect sources.
And this is just duking it out to see which one holds precedent.
What's more significant in terms of the repercussions on the American?
Yeah.
I mean I think I,
I could see where journalists would,
would hold this up as an example of saying this is the same thing.
There's not that you can argue the difference.
Um,
is there,
um,
is there a national
security element to this that takes precedence over a journalist,
right.
To publish something and not disclose the source,
uh,
you know,
that's a court decision.
And what were,
why,
I mean,
why not,
you know,
again,
no one's going to ask me for my opinion on that,
but I can see where I can see where people could draw the comparison and try to
try to argue one side or the other.
Frankly.
Um,
I think if there is a legitimate national security issue,
you've got to weigh in on that side of it.
But that could also be abused.
No doubt.
So you have to be careful about it.
Yeah.
Isn't that the deal?
I mean,
that's the,
the issue that we have with law enforcement and everything that you're dealing
with,
the human element.
You know,
I'm a big fan of law enforcement.
I took a lot of shit from people for saying that because whenever someone says
we shouldn't have cops who I'm like,
I know bad people.
I've met bad people.
You're fucking crazy when people say that we shouldn't have military in your
utopian world and the world would be beautiful and charming and everybody be
grown flowers out of their ass.
Yeah,
that would be nice.
But that's not the world.
Look at what's going on with Isis right now in Syria.
Anybody who doesn't think that you need military to deal with people like that,
you're fucking crazy.
Yeah.
No,
I've spent a lot of time in,
in very,
uh,
unusual in hostile environments where there is no rule of law.
There's no,
uh,
and it's,
it's,
it's not a place people want to be.
Um,
and so I agree with it.
And that's,
and that's also part of the perspective
Yep.
That people think much a massive ignorance of human history,
human history and human motivations.
If you look at the potential,
and if you look at the possible future of humanity,
once we evolve past where we are now,
you have been a thousand years from now,
10,000 years,
holy,
a hundred,
maybe a decade.
Who knows?
But the reality of right now,
if you look at the rest of the world,
look at what's going on with Israel and Gaza right now.
Anybody who thinks you,
you shouldn't have some sort of method of protection,
some sort of method of inf intelligence information and the ability to operate
militarily,
they're crazy,
right?
Right.
And I don't know that human behavior is ever gonna Change.
I mean,
technology adjusts and,
and so we ended up doing things differently because of technology and,
and what that means to us.
But I don't know that,
I don't think we're ever going to evolve beyond this.
We're all just a bunch of,
but don't you think we have from the time we were apes?
I mean we've kind of gotten a little bit better.
I know some guys that haven't,
uh,
don't talk about it.
I'll sharpen that way,
man.
Oh.
How dare you.
Oh,
you walked me into that trap.
I just,
I feel like,
um,
this is probably,
at least in America,
this is fucked up as it is.
This is probably the safest time ever for people.
I really do believe that as far as violent crime,
as far as worried about being attacked by another country,
I think it's probably the safest time ever.
And I would hope that that trend would continue and that this would continue all
across the world and that human beings would slowly but surely sort out all
their bullshit and figure out a way to have a cohesive,
nice,
civilized world that we could all live.
Not In our lifetime,
but,
um,
but it's nice to think about it.
It's just,
I,
I just,
I'm not,
it's a lot like evolution almost.
Yeah.
I've seen some,
some,
you know,
folks do some pretty,
uh,
iffy things out there,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So I think that,
um,
I'm not as optimistic that,
that,
um,
that we,
you know,
that human nature will change.
Um,
I think that it's possible,
but I think that oftentimes we,
you know,
I get asked this question all the time from a,
from folks that are trying to manage security,
uh,
you know,
work on crisis management,
that sort of thing for their companies,
for their families,
whatever it may be.
And um,
you know,
I'm not one of those preppers.
I'm not one of those people who think like that.
It's all gonna fall apart and we're going to be dealing with zombies,
although that,
that will be interesting.
Um,
that would be fun at all.
Yeah.
It wouldn't be fun.
I mean,
unless you got a lot of gear,
you got to,
you got to have a shitty life.
Is that,
oh,
I know.
I know as well.
Yeah.
Well that's where we get that Idaho compound.
No,
I'm kidding.
Yeah.
You don't want the ones that move fast.
I never understood that.
Right.
The fast moving zombies doesn't make any 28 days later,
zombies are scary as fuck.
You know,
my,
uh,
my daughter was fantastic.
She's in college,
she loves Zombie movies.
She refuses to watch 28 days to let it,
cause that freaks her out.
And so anyway,
uh,
but I,
I think that,
um,
you know,
this idea that one of the biggest crisis we actually do face in the,
in the short,
mid term is,
is to our power grid.
So as an example of what I mean by human nature,
um,
I lived in new Canaan,
Connecticut,
so it's a,
it's a very nice little town in Fairfield county.
And,
uh,
when I was working out of my New York office and one of the things I didn't know
about new Canaan was if you buy a house there,
then you have to assume that in town you'll lose power at least every week
during winter because everything's above lines above ground.
So one time,
and after about a year there,
I didn't have any,
uh,
generators.
I'm not smart,
I'm not a handy guy.
And so my wife looks at me,
says,
are you ever going to go out and buy a generator for us?
Because we're the only one on that block that doesn't have a generator.
So the power goes out for three or four days and then winter time it's pretty
damn cold.
First night.
It's fun,
right?
The kids are all,
you know,
I got three boys and the scooter sluggo and Mugsy and they love a camp out.
So first night's great,
second night it's,
it's,
you know,
everybody's freezing the asshole.
So I,
it took me the first winter to figure it out.
I should go out and get a generator.
We had,
we had a power failure.
So I went to a home depot and I went in there and I watched a fight break out
and in a very affluent county of,
of,
of America,
uh,
when the power,
it really only been out for probably about 36 hours at that point.
And I watched a fight break out of a,
one of the last generators.
Apparently that was available.
I mean,
I literally just walked up on this scene and there were people all mashed up and
they'd been handing out numbers and trying to get everybody in order in line.
And I looked at this thing and I thought,
good God.
So then I found the manager and gave him a hundred bucks and got the last
generator.
So That's field expediency,
right?
Their kids.
And it only cost 100 bucks on top of the other,
uh,
on top of the cost of the thing.
So,
um,
and then I proceeded to show you how handy I am.
I proceeded to take it home and run the thing.
We had power.
It was fantastic.
I ran the generator and then I didn't realize necessarily that it needed oil.
So they blew the January,
I blew the generator.
And that was,
that was a,
that was a happy day.
Um,
so my point being is that if the grid goes down,
so we've only got three credits,
uh,
east western Texas,
right around this whole country of ours.
And these grids were never designed.
They were never built to withstand a terrorist attack.
That wasn't the point.
And now,
you know,
the infrastructure is getting old and we're spending a lot of money trying to
harden the facilities and trying to improve and provide more mobile generators.
It's a,
it's a major,
major issue in this country.
And you could imagine if the grid goes out,
um,
what we lose power for say two months,
everything that drives transportation,
um,
trading,
banking,
um,
just general wellbeing of,
of society,
how we all feel about ourselves every day,
uh,
water.
Then we got a problem.
And so my feelings always been,
I would like to think that we'll see the best of ourselves,
uh,
during the course of something like that.
And maybe we will.
Um,
but I,
I sometimes I,
sometimes I find myself being a little bit more cynical than that depends
entirely on the desperation.
There's no food.
You're not going to see the best in people.
No water.
You're not going to see the best in people for,
well,
you know,
people can bond together if they feel like there's a light at the end of the
tunnel.
The real problem was when there's no light,
when there's no light or,
or there's a brighter light over there than what you got,
or they feel like they can get away with carbon,
their own light.
Yeah.
At your expense.
That,
that is a real issue with human nature.
Desperations scary thing.
Those prepper freak me the fuck out man.
Because some of them,
it's like,
almost like they want it to go bad so that they could use all their canned food.
You got to rotate that shit.
Just like you've got to rotate your ammunition.
You've got to rotate.
You can't food.
So don't forget that when you're dealing with your two year supply.
Um,
but no,
I agree with it.
Anyway.
I know where I was going down that rabbit hole.
Well,
just talking about,
we were talking about zombies and your Idaho compound and sluggo and Mugsy
really your kids' names.
Uh,
it basically,
yeah,
that's in the nicknames,
but I don't think they know their real names at this point.
Uh,
sluggo just started kindergarten,
uh,
the other day.
And,
uh,
that was exciting all the way around because he,
you know,
the,
the oldest one,
like a lot of kids,
I don't actually have it.
Nevermind.
I don't want to get started talking about my kids and people are like tuning out
right now.
He's talking about his kids.
Well people like they don't mind talking to him cause,
but that's,
it's an issue that everybody has.
It has children and you worry about the future.
You're worried about,
you know,
not just a future because of,
bullshit that's going on overseas.
But just natural disasters,
things that could happen that could wipe out the grid,
you know,
asteroidal impacts,
etc. What I worry about too,
all those things,
I mean,
all the potential quite pant Damick you know,
even when whatever it is.
But I tell you what,
I spend more time away because I think it's actually more likely or possible is,
um,
most of my time was spent overseas most of my young adult life.
And,
and you could travel to the darkest places out there,
that deepest,
darkest places out there.
And you would
find somebody who would think,
you know,
if I could just get to America then and I,
and I work hard and I can do,
I can do better.
And they honestly believe that.
And people over here used to believe that.
I'm sure that a lot of people still do.
We've got great people.
But I do worry about the erosion of that concept of,
of America being a place where we're VA,
we're very fortunate.
Um,
and you know,
and I understand,
you know,
some more fortunate than,
than a lot of others.
And I,
I,
you know,
that's obvious.
But as a country I worry more about the erosion of our belief in ourselves and
our ability to do great things.
You know,
let me think about what we do with the space program for Fuck Sake.
We put duct tape on a rocket ship and you know,
it took it to the moon and back.
I mean,
we did shit and now we're,
we're begging the Russians for a ride to the space station.
And the Russians of saying,
fuck you.
You know we don't like your stance on Ukraine so you can't go to space.
I Dunno.
Digital is to cancel that.
The to this,
when they canceled the space shuttle but they were keeping up the space station.
I was like,
Whoa,
what's that all about?
Yeah,
that sounds like the most ridiculous shit ever.
It's like,
we're going to have a house in the Hamptons but we're going to give away a car.
Do you have a house in the Hamptons?
No,
I don't.
I mean if you did,
I mean it's nice out there.
A lot of deer though.
You hit your car with him.
A lot of there.
How the fuck do they expect to get out there?
Just seems to me to be so ridiculous that they stopped the space shuttle
program.
Well,
we want to live in a community of nations.
I mean maybe,
I mean some people want to live in a community in nations and that's a lovely
idea.
Just like human nature is going to evolve and moral gonna you know,
like you said at flowers at our ass.
I don't know what that gets us having flowers that are asked,
but it,
it,
uh,
I think that,
you know,
there's,
uh,
there's the reality,
which is that if you don't have somebody at the top,
if you don't have a,
if you don't,
and during the Cold War,
you know,
we had this bipolar situation with us and the Soviets and that worked all right.
As long as there was a balance of power,
physical balance of power.
Um,
but if you don't have somebody at the top of the food chain,
you're going to get kind of where we're going,
which is chaos and people looking to fill that void and we're not gonna be happy
with it.
And if you're not in charge,
then you're looking at somebody's ass in line.
Right.
And that,
you know,
if we're happy with that and we're happy with the ensuing,
potential chaos that that brings,
then fine.
Let's just admit it.
And let's say that's where we're going with all this.
You know,
we,
we want to be average,
but I don't,
I don't believe that's the case with this country.
And,
I dunno,
I know what you're saying.
You know,
you're a patriotic guy and you're looking at the situation at hand and it's a,
it's very uncomfortable.
And I think that the reality of what's going on the foreign crisis is whether
it's what's going on in the Ukraine or what's happening right now.
And I racked this massive power vacuum is being filled by Isis and these
militant jihadists and somebody if somebody is going to be at the top better,
the United States the nicest.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
And you know what honesty and that's,
and that's,
I guess maybe that's what I'm trying to say,
but I'm not saying it very well,
is that I have a great,
uh,
deal of faith in the u s no matter which administration is in charge.
Again,
I don't like think I have a dog in the hunt.
As long as people are working hard and doing,
trying to do the right thing,
whether it's just administration,
previous administration,
whichever one,
I got a lot of faith in the ability or the,
or the desire of this country to do the right thing.
Sometimes we don't do it.
And it takes us a while to course correct,
sometimes longer than we should,
but I do believe that we,
and that's something I took away from the time with,
with with the government.
We try to do the right thing.
So I don't know.
I believe you.
I believe you and I think you're a noble guy.
I mean,
when you're saying this to me,
I don't think you're bullshitting at all.
No,
no.
What I worry most about when it comes to the United States,
when it comes to the future,
the direction of things is the influences that politicians have that are not in
the best interest of Americans.
That to me is one of the scariest things.
The influences of corporations that only look at things in terms of how much
money they can extract from x or y,
which one is going to be more profitable,
profitable for them.
Let's go with why we're going to make more money.
Fuck the American people and that politicians tend to lean towards that because
those are the very people that put them in office in the first place.
They're beholding to them once they get in there.
That I think is one of the biggest threats.
The,
the fear that people have of money over powering the greater good of the,
the actual citizens of the United States.
Yeah.
I think you're,
I think you're absolutely right.
And that's to that I would say what I always say,
which I've been beaten on his stupid drunk for a while is,
is term limits.
I don't think we get big brave decisions in Washington anymore until we get term
limits to wait.
Take that,
that this the system,
which quite frankly the founding fathers never imagined that anybody in their
right mind would want to stay in Washington for 36 years,
you know,
who would want to do that in their mind.
So they didn't put that in there.
And,
and,
and that's the one thing I think that would make a difference,
you know,
give congressmen two,
four year terms,
give senators two,
six year terms and get the fuck out.
Right.
And,
and,
and rotate that.
We got some great people in this country that could step up and be terrific
leaders if given the opportunity.
And if we didn't have to pay a couple hundred million dollars every time we
wanted to run a campaign.
So put finance limits,
that actually means something in there.
And,
and bring that down.
If you can't get your point across in a congress,
Congressional or senate campaign for say you know $1 million,
$2 million from an island,
then you're a fucking moron.
How can you,
how can that not work?
And you and you can only run your campaign for a certain period of time.
How difficult does that,
so I mean the states tried it,
individual states tried to do that and then the supreme court shut it down and
said,
oh,
states can't determine the,
you know,
the,
the term limits for federal positions,
which to me,
I still don't quite get that.
But I agree with you.
But I think that one step we could be taking to try to get that influence of
money out of politics in a meaningful way is,
is term limits.
Get some rotation in there.
Get some fresh blood in there so that you don't have people sitting there and
people and these guys will say,
well,
you gotta.
It takes a long time to understand how Washington works.
Well,
you know,
maybe if you're a moron,
but Washington's a pretty straightforward place at the end of the day and if you
can't figure it out the legislative process in six months,
you're an idiot.
You shouldn't be there.
So that's where I'm,
I'll,
I'll step off my soapbox now,
be circumvented the same way.
They've kind of been with the president where they just have so much massive
money and influence that they essentially,
the two party system is controlled by virtually the same corporations in the
first,
well,
you know what,
I'm not saying that they wouldn't figure out a way to try to game the system at
some point,
but it'd be more difficult.
It would be much more difficult if suddenly,
if I'm a corporation and I know that somebody is going to be on the ways and
Means Committee for the next 24 years,
then I know what I'm going to do.
I know how I'm going to try to influence that position in.
I'm to,
you know,
kind of work that,
that from a lobbying position,
if you're only there for two terms,
I got to change my game plan.
I'm not going to invest all my time and effort and resources into,
into this person.
I'm going to think of it that and,
and you know what it's worth.
I guess my point is it's worth the try.
Is any system going to be perfect?
Well,
no,
of course not.
But the way that it's working right now,
all I know is we've got a city full of dysfunctional people who are,
I mean the congressmen are trying to run for election basically constantly.
A two year term means you're constantly trying to raise money and that's not the
way it should be.
And that's most of their time to most,
most of the time
is fundraising.
Literally 80% of the time that anyone was running for congress,
anyone who's running for Senate,
80% of the time you're trying to raise it.
Right?
And,
and,
and when you send good people there,
then they get cooptive by the system.
And,
and I must be extremely frustrating for the people that go out there with good
intentions and then they realize,
I've got to spend all my time impressing,
you know,
the,
uh,
the congressional leadership with my fundraising prowess.
Yeah.
It's pretty ridiculous.
The situation is without a doubt fucked up.
I heard it here first.
Without a doubt.
Are you,
do you get a sense by paying attention to all this shit that's going on
overseas,
whether it's what's happening in the Ukraine was heating up in North Korea,
what's going on in Iraq and Afghanistan?
Do you get a sense that things are kind of like more chaotic and more hectic now
than they've ever been before?
Um,
I dunno about than they've ever been before.
Certainly in my recent memory.
Yeah.
I don't mix.
I remember it used to be that we'd have the issue,
right?
It was the Balkans.
The Balkans were a mess.
They were a big stinking mess and it was very violent.
Um,
there was a little lovely period of time where Haiti was the only real big
concern.
Um,
we had the cold war era and that was very comforting for a lot of people because
you knew who the enemy was and you knew what the,
how the game was played in a sense.
Um,
and,
but right now with the flash points that we've got,
we've got the,
I mean the Chinese are,
uh,
increasingly aggressive and in an effort to try to retake the Pacific,
which they've always been pissed off that we've really,
basically,
I've owned since World War II and the Russians,
the Middle East situation obviously.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I'd say it's more chaotic now than it has been in recent memory.
I don't think,
I don't think that's a,
that's not a big statement
is that what happens is they'll just an ebb and flow when it comes to these sort
of situations.
When,
when it comes to like what's going on in the world,
power struggles,
then the power struggles that resolved and then new resistance builds up.
I mean,
is that in your experience how things go?
Well I think it,
you,
you minimize the chaos by being consistent.
And what am I mean by that?
Is,
is it,
you know,
and as foreign policy,
as an example,
if you're foreign policy message is consistent and uh,
and strong and clear and there's no misunderstanding by either your allies or
the people that,
uh,
that are against us,
then you can minimize the chaos that exists if it's not consistent and there's
confusion over where we stand.
And I'm saying we,
because you know,
okay,
fine,
we're still at the top of the,
of the food heap.
Whether people are comfortable with that or not,
I don't know.
But,
um,
so if,
if we're not consistent in that message,
then there's confusion and that's where you start to get problems because you
started getting people probing at the perimeter,
trying to see what exactly is going on,
what they can get away with.
We start getting less leverage.
I mean,
you know,
we're getting situation in the Middle East now where countries are acting
completely without,
uh,
consulting,
with the u s you wouldn't have had that 30 years ago.
You know,
it just wouldn't happen like Egypt,
Egypt,
and I think,
uh,
in,
in what they consider to be their own best interest.
The Saudis,
the Saudis are enormously,
uh,
pissed off at us still over of what they view as,
as the current administration is failure to,
um,
you know,
work with them to try to resolve some issues out in the Middle East and they
feel as if we've sort of abdicated responsibility now whether we have or not,
whether it's the right thing to do or not.
I'm just saying from a policy perspective,
um,
you know,
if what we want to do is be isolationists then be very clear about that.
Say this is all we're going to do.
These are our parameters.
That's it.
So everybody knows good,
all good with it,
fine,
get on with it.
But you know,
the mixed messages or the problem,
I mean,
that's,
you know,
I think that's,
uh,
so being clear
in,
in one way being patriotic and being an isolationist and isolationists and
another way it meddling and foreign governments sending out a,
B and part of their political process,
all that jazz.
Well,
I think that,
yeah,
exactly.
I mean saying,
okay,
we don't really want to be involved.
Here's a red line.
You're past the red line.
I'll keep fine.
We're going to do something else over here.
Um,
you know,
we're going to pivot to Asia and I don't mean to pick on the current
administration.
I got a lot of respect for some of the folks in there.
But,
um,
there's a,
you know,
there's,
there's a lack I think,
of consistency and there's certainly,
I think in the sense of how the Chinese are behaving,
how the Russians are behaving,
how there's certain countries in the Middle East are currently behaving.
I think it's an indication that they don't necessarily believe we're engaged
and,
and that either worrisome or delights them,
you know,
depending on what position they hold.
So,
you know,
and I don't think we have the luxury of,
of disengaging.
You know,
again,
I,
my,
my experience has been when there's a vacuum,
you know,
shit happens.
Well,
that's what we're seeing right now in Iraq,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's one of the scariest times ever for the folks who live there.
And what we're seeing in terms of,
uh,
these jihadists extremists,
this is like,
this is as ramped up as we've ever seen it before.
And this is a direct response to the power vacuum,
right?
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
And you know,
we can argue all day long.
Okay.
You know,
should we have gone in,
you know,
should we not have a,
okay,
fine,
but the situation is that it's fucked up and we got to deal with this right now
whether the 2001 decision was correct or not,
it is what it is.
Exactly.
And so now we've got to deal with it,
otherwise we're going to pay a big price for this.
This is the first time that they've gained this sort of territorial integrity
from an extremist point of view and they're consolidating territory there and
own the entire northern province in Syria and an additional the territory moving
east and up through Aleppo,
uh,
they're controlling a border posts,
on along the Golan Heights.
They controlling Botha porcelain Turkey.
Um,
and they've moved obviously into Iraq there,
you know,
not very far away that could piss on bag that at this point and they're
consolidating that turf.
And that's a huge recruitment tool for them overseas,
which is why we're seeing their numbers,
you know,
kind of grow exponentially at this point is because they've got the turf of this
caliphate that they've been talking about for years and years.
Finally they got this physical vision of this thing.
They've got the resources from over running the banks and the various,
you know,
military bases in Syria and Iraq.
I mean,
good God,
they've gotten their hands on multiple divisions worth of gear.
And so it's,
it's,
we're going to have to deal with it and somebody has got to put boots on the
ground,
whether it's us or somebody else.
It'd be nice to see the Turks step up cause they got a lot to lose on this one.
It'd be nice to see the Turk step up and,
and uh,
and get involved.
But somebody's got to put boots on the ground,
cause airstrikes alone.
I'm not gonna cut it.
Is this one of those situations to where it's difficult to get people
enthusiastic about engaging because of all the years of war that people
disagreed with Iraq and Afghanistan especially.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I mean,
this is a much more imminent threat.
Well it is,
but it's hard to explain that to people who are fatigued.
And I understand that 100%.
I mean,
you know,
we're all tired of the freaking war on terror while tired of Iraq.
We're all tired of Afghanistan.
And I understand that nobody wants to deal with it,
but just kind of want it to go away.
Isn't,
that's not a sound national security policy
future.
I mean,
what,
what can be done to sort of mitigate all that?
Well,
the problem is that we're now in a position,
I mean,
if we're just talking about isis,
the Islamic state went out in a position where we've got some pretty strange
bedfellows.
Iran is engaged against them.
Obviously the Shiite regime,
they've been putting boots on the ground in Iraq for some time now trying to
prop up Mollica who's now gone,
uh,
Syria.
Bashar Assad has been,
you know,
authorizing airstrikes in there.
So in a sense,
if we go into Syria,
you know,
and,
and try to kick some ass with Isis,
we're on the side of the Iranians and Assad and this White House is really,
really unlikely to want to be seen in,
in,
in the public eye as taking sides with a side.
So this is probably the most complex situation they've got going right now is
how to do this.
Um,
and that's why I say they're the best way to go about it is to strong arm if
necessary.
Uh,
the Turks,
a Jordanian Saudis to the degree we can,
we don't have much leverage with the Saudis anymore.
Um,
to try to get them on board,
get an allied force in there because we can do it.
It's not like we can't,
you know,
uh,
defeat them.
We just don't have a strategy for doing it right now.
We've got a strategy to contain them.
Yeah.
I'm not necessarily the biggest Obama Fan,
but man has this fucking guy walked into a hornet's nest from the moment he got
into the White House.
I mean talk about a chaotic eight years right now.
Absolutely.
And they walked in without really,
I think,
uh,
appreciating how bad it could be.
Obviously a,
and walking in also with not as much interest in the international scene as in
doing some domestic changes.
Well,
I remember when he was debating McCain and he was talking about going into
Afghanistan and then we'll just go in and take care of things and came was like,
do you even fucking know what Afghanistan is?
Do you understand how it works?
Or,
I remember when Mccain said that that place is operated essentially the same way
since Alexander the Great.
Do you,
do you recognize that it's not,
you can't just go in there,
right.
It's,
it's,
it's the definition.
It's,
it's a,
it's like Libya Libya's hot mess right now by the way.
Nobody's focusing on live.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They've just,
the,
the uh,
the extremists have just taken over the airport in Tripoli.
The,
basically they,
they,
they have taken over the country.
There's almost nothing related to sort of a pseudo federal government running
Libya anymore.
It's a,
it's a disaster.
But we can only focus on one thing at a time apparently.
So,
you know,
right now we're looking at Isis,
but I think,
uh,
you look at Afghanistan and that's a,
that's a perfect example.
We didn't need another case study.
We've got a case study of what the Russians did.
We spend a lot of time,
I was in there when,
when we were trying to get the Soviets out,
we spend a lot of time trying to push them out and they went through the same
process we did after five years.
They were just trying to get the fuck out of there.
They already realized it was a failure situation to try.
And so what did they do?
They retreated to the urban centers.
That's what we did.
They couldn't figure out how to get a government that would stay in place after
they left.
Same problem.
We're having all this,
we know that they went through,
um,
I had one of my first hires in diligence,
uh,
for all your information and security needs was a former,
a military intelligence officer and he's a former tank driver too,
for the Russian military.
And,
uh,
he told me,
he grabbed me.
I remember it was,
we went into a,
into a Tora Bora.
And,
uh,
he said,
you know,
don't stay.
You can't stay there.
So they're like cockroaches.
You step on them here,
they show up over there.
Don't stay.
He was still carrying around shrapnel from the time the Soviet occupation of
Afghanistan.
We didn't need to go all the way back through history to understand how this was
not going to work.
And I hate to say this,
and it does not.
I'm not,
I'm not doing any disservice to the terrific men and women have served over
there,
lost their lives and wounded.
The Taliban have no place to go.
It's like the Vietcong,
where do we think they're going to go?
So once we're finished there,
when they take back over,
we shouldn't be that surprised.
So I,
I'm not an optimistic yeah,
we did a brilliant tactical mission there,
but by the spring of 2002,
we should have walked out the door so that if you do this again,
if you allow your place to be used to,
uh,
reach out to the west to come back and kill more of you.
But W nation building,
I don't give a shit whether he raised their literacy rate by two or 3% or build
another road.
They don't know what we're trying to sell them,
never have.
So that's,
I'm very frustrated with it.
That Afghan policy is vary.
Enormously frustrating.
It seems incredibly frustrating.
But what could be done?
Is there a way to handle it better?
I mean,
what,
what could be done?
Well,
once again,
I mean,
when that category,
why you'd Kinda,
you know,
you broke it,
we'll kind of guitars,
um,
you know,
we can argue about the wisdom of what we did,
but you're right.
I mean,
now you've got to look at it from a practical point of view.
Um,
frankly,
uh,
anything we do in Afghanistan,
it's sort of like a holding a enterprise,
right?
So as long as we stay there,
we can maintain some semblance of not a shitstorm.
Uh,
once we leave,
then it degenerated.
So I,
you know,
I think anything we do there is simply a containment action.
So does it just become the United States of Afghanistan?
We take over and just found it on the poppy seeds and the fucking minerals in
the Ma in the mountains.
This goes back to that,
to whole narcotics there.
Hold on.
It's,
it's important to look at,
I mean,
if you really do think about what the scenario is over there,
90% of the world's opium comes from there.
And there's a massive amount of calcium and ion and the minerals in the
mountains.
Well,
what the fuck else can anybody do other than try to figure out one way to fund
staying there?
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's a,
uh,
one of the most unsatisfying discussions you can ever have.
We,
well,
there's no good answer.
There's no good answer.
Leaving sock Stang sucks,
right?
Both of them.
Right?
And,
and,
and again,
we're,
we're having this discussion in public that we're a public is entirely,
yeah.
Rightfully so fatigued with this whole thing.
Not just fatigue but ignorant.
Right.
You ignorant of it.
Yeah.
I've read quite a bit about it,
but I guarantee you I'm ignorant.
I mean,
if I was over there,
I'd probably have a better understanding if I was over there for a decade,
maybe I would scratch the surface.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.
Yeah.
I see what you mean.
But it's,
um,
but yeah,
we've,
we're,
we've got a lot of flash points right now.
We've got a lot of big issues that are,
that are happening.
And,
um,
you know,
now we've got the midterm elections coming up,
so I don't think anything,
nothing big in a way it's going to happen in Washington.
Do you think any of this could have been avoided by not going into Iraq and not
going into Afghanistan?
Or was that kind of shit inevitable anyway?
Because it was all this with having a ruthless dictator,
like Saddam was saying,
that's no picnic.
Having a guy like that running a country of this evil fucking sociopathic serial
killer sons.
I mean that guy was a ruthless piece of shit.
No,
absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean people say,
wow,
we should've left them in place.
Well,
you know what the mindset at the time and people have won.
Yeah.
I have a hard time remembering going back to what it was like,
right after nine,
11,
people thought shit was going to happen every single fucking now.
Right.
And you it got it got overrun with Neil.
Kahn says,
no doubt about that.
They,
you know,
they had an agenda,
they had a plan that there,
this is what they were going to do.
Um,
now there was also,
and I do know this,
there was also agreement from a lot of allies that this was a problem that had
to be dealt with.
So it wasn't just the u s saying,
we're going to Russian,
you know,
cause that's a conspiracy or we're going to go in there cause we would get their
oil really well.
Um,
there,
there were a lot of allies that we believe in that.
And unfortunately,
and this goes to show you how you gotta,
you gotta be very careful about your intelligence operations.
A lot of it was based on just crap,
bullshit,
you know,
and,
but,
but the time at the time,
the way that we thought and the,
and the fear that existed and,
and the way that people will said whatever it takes to protect the homeland,
even if that means going into a rock,
you know,
because that's going to be the next flashpoint.
Um,
so I'm not,
I'm not wanting to say you got a second guess decisions that happened in the
past because it's a complete waste of fucking breath.
But I mean,
I guess you could,
you obviously can learn things from it.
But,
um,
more to your point,
which is a much more important question,
is what do you do about it now?
What,
what no one has a good solution.
No one has,
no one is standing up on top of a soapbox saying,
this is what needs to be done.
If we do this,
we're going to have peace on earth.
Right?
And you're right,
the,
you know,
the Republicans are beating the Democrats over the head saying,
hey,
you got,
but the Republican side,
you know,
come up,
come up with a decision,
come up with an idea.
You know,
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not a fan again of Obama could change your fucking Sarah Palin was the God
damn vice president United States right now.
How the world would be looking at us.
Well that's why I say I,
you know,
another thing I think is,
I can go back to term limits and finance reform
is I think we get a lot of,
we get a deeper pool of potential candidates and we surprised ourselves with how
many really good,
smart,
uh,
dynamic people are out there who might be willing to step in if they didn't have
to go through this insane political process.
So,
Eh,
yeah.
What do I know?
What do I,
I don't even know how we got on the subject.
It's,
it's a,
it's Wednesday evening.
Let's talk about your show,
man.
It's used to be called America declassified.
And what are you guys going to call it now?
Now it's going to be called world access,
world access.
We're almost finished filming episodes.
We've been all over the country,
a great country,
seeing terrific sites,
talking to really cool people,
um,
exploring things,
doing shit,
chasing Burmese pythons in the everglades,
a roping in the,
in the glacial ice caves up in Alaska,
uh,
tracking grizzlies and beautiful Yellowstone park.
If people haven't been to Yellowstone.
Oh my God.
Incredible.
It's incredible.
And,
uh,
you got to,
you could do yourself a favor and kind of,
I tell,
don't kill everybody.
Get that before that happens.
The world before the end of the world,
like you where it starts.
Yeah.
Idaho be blown off the map if that happens.
But um,
so we'll California,
yeah,
exactly.
But wait,
so it's going to air in the late fall.
Uh,
will the access,
it's,
uh,
the production companies into go film
is that a San Francisco and Los Angeles,
a great bunch of people that's on the travel channel.
And uh,
that's all can think to say that's clever.
What was it like when you had investigate area 51?
Was that,
uh,
a Hornet's nest of looney tunes.
They can,
that there's aliens that are pickled in a fucking mason jar somewhere down in
the basement.
Yeah.
Well not the agency called me up and said,
look,
here's what you can and you can't disclose a don't tell him about the sub
basement where we keep the Allianz.
Um,
and uh,
so I think I kept those secrets pretty well.
Uh,
it's area 51 is a,
is a fascinating,
fascinating place.
And um,
it's what's interesting is tracking the history of sort of our developmental,
um,
air platforms and looking at the timeline,
the chronology of getting sidings and things and that,
that to me is pretty cool because we were coming up with some pretty bizarre,
you know,
air platforms for surveillance in particular and they,
shit,
this shit was flying around the desert,
you know,
being tested.
Some of it works,
some of it didn't.
And you can imagine it,
you look at the timeline of people going,
oh my God,
what the Hell is something something?
And you see this happening and you understand why people were losing their
minds.
But,
well,
it's,
it's people trying to believe their eyes are trying to understand what they're
seeing is a real issue.
We replayed a video yesterday on the podcast,
have a bear that's something wrong with its front paws.
It was walking on two feet and it looked like fucking big flood.
Oh yeah,
I saw the,
I saw,
that's ridiculous.
If you saw that,
you would think it's big foot.
When,
uh,
after September 11th,
we were filming a fear factor,
a down near Edwards air force base.
Um,
we were,
uh,
out in the desert doing these stunts and a stealth fighters would fly overhead.
And if you had never seen one of those before,
if you didn't know what that was,
right,
that looks like a Goddamn Ufo and now it looks like a spaceship from another
planet.
This black thing that's not shaped like any normal plain and it's flying low and
fast.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm looking at Dalian.
A lot of that technology developed at the agency,
uh,
by the science and technology group.
You know,
a lot of that early days in particular,
uh,
surveillance,
craft,
incredible what they were doing it,
how does he recruit guys instead of like getting them a filter or like the top
people instead of them going into the public sector and you know,
making money doing something else.
That's good.
I mean,
you know what they got,
they got a huge number of applicants.
I got,
I mean you,
you'd be amazed at how many people apply to it to work there.
Uh,
in,
in all cross the board operations,
intelligence group,
SNT,
admin and logistics.
They just get a very deep pool of candidates and you're right.
I mean these guys aren't looking to join for the money.
They can make a lot more money at Twitter or wherever.
Um,
yeah,
I just came to me,
I'm not that,
not that plugged into my page or whatever.
You have a term page fellow.
Yeah,
I do.
And,
and uh,
and I'm getting better at and understanding how you use it.
I've only got,
I've gone through like 800 tweets.
I'm always fascinated by how many tweets I've done because I think,
wow,
how much time am I spending doing this?
Um,
but they,
you know,
they,
they get great people applying and part of it's just knowing that they're going
to be in the agency,
they're going to have access to,
uh,
both great people,
great technology,
sort of cutting edge thinking,
um,
and as patriotism involved too.
I mean,
they want to work there.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
I don't,
I can't,
I don't want to,
I don't want to sound like a rose colored glasses on.
It's a bureaucracy like a lot of other places,
you know,
things could be done better for sure.
Uh,
but you know,
my experience was always,
always terrific if any kids are out there listening,
I highly recommend you apply
now as far as like,
what's going on in area 51 today.
That's not the same thing.
Right.
Like then they move their operations to a different area because so many people
are paying attention to it now.
Yeah.
They moved to woodland hills.
Calabasas,
I'm getting bad.
This info.
Yeah,
I know they did move it because it took a little too much heat and so,
uh,
so they,
they thought it might be better to have other,
uh,
facilities,
but it's still true to this day is that they,
uh,
inside the agency.
And I actually took a,
I actually took him to go films for this for the second season of,
of world access on travel.
I took them into the agency headquarters not too long ago,
a couple of months ago,
and we did a story inside the headquarters and part of it was based on,
we've got a museum inside there that's open to the staff obviously and,
and,
and then a visiting,
you know,
liaison partners and dignitaries to come in and you look at the history and the
agency started out of oss,
out of the military and you look at the history of it in,
in,
in all aspects of it,
operations,
science,
technology,
whatever it is.
And it's a,
it's a pretty incredible,
it's a pretty incredible place.
But they always,
when they're developing technology,
when the developing ideas,
when the developing operations incident response to something,
it's a response to a task.
They don't just sit around unlike maybe a tech company in Palo Alto or
something.
They don't just sit around and throw a ball at the wall and think,
you know,
let's come up with a clever idea.
It's always in response to a task that they get from,
uh,
well from the administration says we need to solve this problem.
And,
and typically the administrations over the years,
they go to the agency first because they know it's,
you know,
they'll,
they'll cut through the crap.
They've got people who will sit down and come up with,
with,
you know,
scenario that,
this might work,
you know,
and it's,
and,
and they work quickly.
Um,
and again,
they've got terrific creative people.
Listen to me on,
I'm a booster.
I believe you are a little bit,
I am a sister.
I have a book that's cause you're proud.
You're,
you're a real patriot.
I appreciate it that well,
it was good.
It did.
It did work.
I mean,
look at the stealth bomber,
look at all the shit that they did,
create it.
Look at the B 51 like all the different,
now I know a lot of shit they,
they created out of there.
That's pretty God damn amazing.
And some of the most they've got,
they've just got a,
you look at some of the,
some of the shit.
I mean,
anybody,
if this is a good point,
you're not going to get inside the agencies museum.
Well you can if you watched the show in the fall,
but uh,
they have a spy museum in Washington DC,
which is actually worth visiting.
It's a really good,
it was,
it was.
Anybody can go to it.
It's in DC and it's a,
it's a,
it's a great time out.
Kids love it.
But the,
uh,
but it operates on a couple levels.
One is sort of for the kids,
but one is,
is it's a really very,
very smartly
done a museum looking at espionage through the years trade craft and a variety
of operations that have happened over the years.
Fantastic facility.
So people should go to that one too.
Yeah.
Technology spying technology.
So fascinating.
My Buddy Mike worked at the American embassy in Russia and they would find the
surveillance devices that the Russians would install in these buildings that
were so sophisticated.
He said they had found a listening device that was powered on the swaying of the
building itself.
The swaying and the movement of the building itself in the wind was actually
powering this device.
They said it was unlike anything that they had ever thought of before.
And it was just mind blowing that these equally intelligent people with a
completely different language in another country had come up with some
alternative path to,
uh,
to listen in on people.
Yeah.
The Russians Soviets during the Cold War in particular where we're,
you know,
a,
because they dumped unlimited resources into it and maybe because they were
highly motivated and aggressive.
Um,
they were very,
very worthy.
Adversary is still are.
Um,
but yeah,
are,
are you cold war history,
um,
is is a fascinating thing.
And you look at,
you look at the technology that was developed out of that and,
and a,
and a lot of that ended up being used for the private sector and the development
of everything from smart phones to a internet applications.
So if variety thing,
so a lot of the crap that gets put together,
it gets,
uh,
thought of and designed a inside the Intel community ends up benefiting the
private sector and the,
I just a person on the street,
you know,
commercial people is also fascinating too,
that both the Russians and the United States battled over who would get the best
Nazi scientists,
you know,
dirty secret of the Cold War and of the space.
Race knew those minds.
I mean,
you've got to be,
sits pragmatic,
you know,
choices you've got to at time those choices.
It's a choice that nobody wanted to admit for the longest time.
Right.
That Wernher von Braun was a Nazi.
He was absolutely the Simon Wiesenthal Center said if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes against humanity.
And that's a pretty amazing thing to say when you consider the fact that that
guy was absolutely necessary to,
uh,
take part in the space race and that the Soviets had Nazis,
we had Nazis.
You will make it pragmatic decisions in part because,
um,
you know,
I,
well part it was a,
well we lived in and um,
I don't know that you could do that today in terms of me.
I mean,
look at the situation in Syria,
you know,
if we side with Assad,
is that politically acceptable here in the states politically turned down to do
that,
that these isis guys were super smart at social media and so we fucking hire him
to run the United States Facebook page and we'll go,
what the fuck?
You guys got these jihadis and there,
you know,
nobody would buy that today.
No,
I don't think so.
That's a tough sell.
What was it about the Nazis that made them so good at engineering and
technology?
I mean,
it is really incredible when you think about German engineering and technology
to this day is thought of as in the highest regard.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's true.
And it goes back,
obviously he goes back a long,
long time.
So,
um,
yeah,
obviously they took a left turn.
That's an a brilliant statement with the home.
That whole Nazi Shanana obviously.
Yeah,
obviously,
yeah.
Discounting their social activity.
Just the engineering and technology.
I'm always fascinated by what is it that causes one country,
one nation tick cell in a radical way above and beyond others.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
it's good.
It's a good question.
Yeah.
You look at some that just continued to keep,
you know,
kind of like ticking along at a certain level.
They can't seem to raise the bar and it's,
it's tough.
I mean it's,
who knows what it is.
That's why,
again,
I go back to that same thing about the u s I think we can do anything.
Anything we put our minds to,
if we have,
if we have the collective will,
if we,
if we set our minds to it.
And I just,
I hope we maintain that,
that belief structure for our kids.
I tell my kids that all the time.
I said how fortunate they are to be living in this country,
how fortunate they are to have the circumstances they have to,
I mean,
not just putting food on the table,
but you know,
the opportunity for education,
all these things and to live in a place where you know,
hard work is valued and listened to me.
I said,
no,
but you're right.
No,
look,
you listen.
Don't worry about it man.
You're a real patriot.
And I think that's admirable.
I think that,
uh,
for the longest time,
look,
I'm a car fan.
I'm a,
I love cars.
And for the longest time American cars were God damn embarrassing.
You know,
while German cars are producing these,
they were producing these incredible Porsche's and the Italians are making these
fantastic Ferrari's.
We were making shitty mustangs and the fucking seventies pinto something
ramblings.
Remember the Gremlin tasters and cars for a while,
and then something happened when the gas crisis came along.
We made shit for 20 years,
but finally now American cars are bounding back.
Like the new corvette is a marvel of engineering.
I mean all these European car magazines and saying it's one of the greatest cars
ever made.
Yeah,
I read.
So I read some comparisons on,
it's fantastic.
Incredible.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's great to finally see stuff like that happening.
why didn't it happen a long time ago?
It's a,
I'm absolutely fascinated by technology,
mostly because I'm a moron because I can't,
I can't engineer anything.
So,
and I see how someone figures out how to make a car where when you're taking a
turn,
the computer adjust the shocks to put more pressure on one side to flat out the
fucking a man.
That's what I say.
I say if,
if,
if everybody was like me,
we'd still be trying to figure out how to make a wheel and how to build a fire
close.
If everybody was like me,
it'd be fucking stone rock tools.
That's it.
We'd make bang in Flint together,
probably doing a shitty job,
you know?
Yeah.
I,
you look at Shit that gets put together,
the technology of it all and you think,
wow,
who,
who the hell came up with?
How did you think of,
how did you think of that?
But thank God they do that.
And then there's others,
you know,
who would get the job done in other ways.
But I buddy of mine,
I met his first car,
he'd pulled up in front of my parents house.
He was so proud.
I was,
I was young.
He's so proud of it.
It was a Gremlin.
So proud of this classic rambler.
And I remember walking out there,
even at that young age where I just,
I just gotten my,
my a learner's permit.
Even at that young age,
I knew he had just bought himself a piece of shit.
And I thought,
how do I tell him that?
That was one of my first lessons in diplomacy.
How do I look at this guy who was so proud of his fucking piece of shit and say,
yeah,
that's,
yes,
it's great there,
pal.
There's not much you can do.
You can't do anything.
Yeah.
Especially the guys first car.
My first car was at a fucking hunk of shit.
1973 Chevelle SS.
Nice.
It was nice for a day until the engine blew.
The first day I had it,
or the second day,
one day,
the next day the engine seized up that had me,
I had a,
I had a 77 Granada.
Ooh,
my first purchase,
1977 we're not Ford Granada.
It was very nice with it.
Landau roof and a bench seats
and I remember the guy,
the guy said at the car dealership,
he said,
do you want it?
You want an eight track in that or do you want a cassette deck?
Like cassette deck is new.
And I said,
what's a cassette deck?
And he showed it to me.
I remember it standing there.
He showed it to me and I said,
no,
I,
I'll take that a track.
That's just not going anywhere.
It sounded better,
didn't it?
Supposedly.
I thought they did.
But that was the knock on is an eight track.
Had a better sound.
It was just you had to deal with these fucking bricks,
put it in there,
could chunk whatever it,
wherever it was in that tape.
That's where that song started to where it was.
And then you'd have a shoe box full of him cause that's the only way you could
store your eight tracks in your car.
Wasn't shoe boxes.
My family never had one.
But my friend Javier did and he,
his,
his mom had a,
she had an eight track of Pablo Cruz,
that song,
uh,
when my baby,
when my baby's miles at me,
I go to Rio.
And I remember like seeing that thing in the car going,
I was incredible.
Sound is coming out of it whenever you want.
It's not even a radio.
What a coincidence.
I was in the agency,
I spent like eight months undercover in a Pablo Cruz cover band working over say
no,
I did.
I didn't.
But it would have been good cover because nobody would,
so you had to start singing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Did you have to go into coverage?
Did you ever have to do shit y'all?
Yeah.
I mean I spent all my time in operations and that's just what you did.
You worked in,
in whatever it might be,
their country.
Um,
not really.
No.
I've got a great relationship in part because I could you keep your my Yap shut.
Yeah.
But um,
yeah,
operations working in it.
I will say this about operations and working on it covers if you like to act.
And I found that I did then it's,
it's great.
It's very,
I mean,
and we've got everything from our disguise teams inside the agency.
We've got some of the guys are Hollywood people out of Hollywood clamor to,
to get in there and work with the agency disguise unit because it's,
it's,
so again,
it's so cutting edge and they how cutting edge,
do you ever have a guy dressed up like a check?
Like an old lady like me and my free time or
pretend to be a woman like big Momma's house?
No,
nothing like that.
Nothing like that.
No,
but you don't have to be a fat lady would be a thin lady.
We had fat suits,
full overhead masks and,
and you had to,
you had to be comfortable operating in,
in,
in pretty heavy disguise sometimes depending on where we were and where we were
operating at fat suits.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
Wow.
I know it's not like fat best from Austin Powers,
but not quite that fast.
But I mean,
because what are you trying to do?
You're trying to change your appearance quickly.
Trying to figure out ways to quickly but professionally and to withstand
scrutiny to change your parents.
People make snap judgments about people.
And in terms of surveillance,
people make quick decisions.
Okay,
I got,
I,
I'm,
I'm following this person,
uh,
brown shoes.
Um,
you blonde hair.
Good.
Got It.
And you know,
and that's how they,
you know,
surveillance teams will tee off of certain things.
So if you can change your profile,
just,
you know,
in certain ways,
then that's very beneficial.
But,
and then operating overseas and places where necessarily I might not blend in
unnecessarily.
So,
but if you,
if you like to act an operating on the cover was fantastic.
I happen to enjoy it a great deal.
About acting once you got out of the agency,
like uh,
acting,
acting?
No,
I would know.
I didn't even know how that would work,
but I mean a co hosting a show on travel channel world access is pretty good.
Why they change the world access and classified sounds like better for a former
CIA.
They wanted to lighten it up a little bit,
take it a little bit away from sort of the conspiracy and the dark side and
focus more on just going to great places around the country.
And hopefully that makes sense.
So world access and maybe next season for the next season we'll do actual world
access as opposed to us access.
But this show for Scifi,
I called Joe Rogan questions everything and they were trying to get me to do
sort of along the same lines of the Jesse Ventura show,
the conspiracy theory.
They were really into conspiracy theories when I started doing the show.
But the more I started doing it,
the more I was like,
most of this is bullshit.
Like you're,
you're,
you're doing a show where you're exploring bullshit,
but you don't necessarily want to call bullshit because you want to keep this
air of mystery,
the change of people tuning in.
Right?
Yeah.
I,
I agree with you.
it can be very difficult to keep that up for any period of time.
Right.
And then,
and so I like to think,
I mean,
I,
I approached this,
this,
uh,
this second season's coming up,
this world access show it,
I approach it,
you of like anybody was sitting on a sofa.
You know,
I'm a fairly simple guy,
so when I go to some of these places,
literally I'm kind of staring there,
you know,
slack,
jawed and amazed at what I'm seeing,
whether it's the,
the geography or whether it's just dealing with the people at what goes on there
or whatever it may be.
So I like to think I'm,
I'm,
you know,
I'm the guy that's sitting on the sofa watching this shit and I'm reacting the
same way they would.
I'm just fascinated by it.
So it's difficult to do sometimes with conspiracies because you feel like a lot
of the conspiracies,
they've been beaten to the ground and you're hearing stuff that you've heard
before.
You're looking at shit that you looked up before.
But not to say that it's not entertaining.
It is.
But anyway,
we'll see.
I mean even the science channel,
which is supposed to be about science,
they have so many of these God damn Ufo shows where they talk to these people
and they all have fucking stories.
But that's when it boils down to it.
That's all there is,
is stories,
right?
Stories from questionable people and the stories are almost all goofy and you
just get,
it gets weary after a while.
You're like,
what kind of a show?
My making,
this is all
bullshit.
Yeah,
it's stories.
It's,
it's,
it's Ufo,
it's a ghost.
Stories,
stories or eat and shit and going around to restaurants.
Uneaten food.
Right.
But you know,
Andrew Zimmerman,
like that kind of thing.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and you know,
I mean,
I can see why people find it interesting.
But what I like about this,
this,
this show now is,
is just,
we're going to some fantastic places.
We're seeing shit that you gotta make an effort to get to.
So everything that we're doing is basically got to work to get there.
But if you do,
it's well worth it.
And it's not just sort of the same beat and path,
you know,
not walking up to the edge of the grand canyon staring out and going to Aa.
Okay,
that's nice.
It's,
you know,
get outside your comfort zone,
travel a little bit more,
make the effort,
and you'll be amazed at what the country has to offer.
Oh,
there's some incredible things in this country and people don't realize the fact
that out of these 50 states there,
I mean,
everybody thinks of New York,
Chicago,
San Francisco,
you,
we,
we think of these spots that you need to visit.
But there's so many amazing spots.
There's so much shit to see.
You could have a thousand episodes just traveling to different cities and
checking out.
Yeah.
Weird Shit that people do.
Absolutely.
No,
I just looked at my watch.
I realized if I don't leave now,
I may not make my flight.
Wait,
where's your flight?
What time's your flight?
I don't even want to tell you if you don't want to tell me what time.
Well,
I probably probably,
I may not make it.
Okay.
All right,
so should we wrap this out?
It's about 20 after four.
This my flow.
Okay.
Yeah,
you're fucked.
it's in Burbank.
Is it from Burbank?
It's not from Burbank.
Oh yeah.
Well you'll be okay.
We'll be okay.
We'll see what if you leave right now,
we'll,
we'll wrap it up right now.
Mike,
Thank you very much.
This has been fantastic.
I really appreciate it.
Anything you want me to promote?
Anything I'd be more than happy to do so just let us know.
Promoted the shit out of the show on travel channel and it's a great show but I,
if I talk about it one more time,
all,
I don't feel like a pushing tin.
Okay.
If folks,
you can follow Mike on Twitter.
His handle is a m B company man.
That's your handle on Twitter and a the show.
Once again,
the old one is America declassified and the new one is world access and it's on
the travel channel travel channel.
Thanks so much.
Thank you very much brother.
I appreciate it.
And thanks also to our sponsors.
Thanks to stamps.com go to stamps.com use the code word,
j.
R.
E.
N,
save yourself some money,
including $55 a free postage and a free digital scale.
What else do we have today on it and on it,
and on a.com o.
N.
I,
t,
use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all settlements will be back
tomorrow with Greg Fitzsimmons.
Big Kiss.
Yeah.